hello everyone welcome to the June 2023
ask me anything addition to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll the only thing really on my mind
these days you know the semester is over
here at Johns Hopkins I'm not traveling
for the next several weeks at least so
I'm finishing the book volume two of the
biggest ideas in the universe which is
going to be called quanta and Fields
this one has been a lot of work I mean
of course it's taken longer than it
should have because I got a new job and
flew across the country and helped to
fix up a house before moving into it and
taught two courses and a whole bunch of
other things there's a lot going on so
we originally had hoped that Volume 2
would be coming out a year after volume
one which would put it this fall uh I'm
not done and it takes almost a year to
get a book out once you've handed it in
so no it's not going to be coming out
this fall it'll come out sometime first
half of next year I presume 2024 I'm
hoping that since I am not going to move
across the country again and my job is
already settled here that the book after
that book three in the series which will
be complexity and emergence that will
come out about a year after volume two
so volume two that I'm finishing up
right now
um you know I go back and forth because
it's super ambitious volume one was
pretty ambitious you know volume one
taught you relativity both special and
general I mean it starts very slowly
going with Newtonian mechanics what is
space what is time there are a lot of
words but eventually the equations start
coming and I teach you how to do
calculus and things like that and then
non-reboni and ribani in Geometry I
should say no nuclearian geometry uh
culminating in general relativity and
that's a lot for a trade book type of
audience this book I'm doing quantum
mechanics of course but actually in in
book two the quantum mechanics is going
to go by pretty quickly I am not
dwelling on the intricacies of quantum
mechanics certainly not the
interpretations thereof or foundational
questions like we did in something
deeply hidden because most of the book
is going to be about Quantum field
Theory and particle physics so I'll be
talking about Feynman diagrams and
lagrangians and effective field Theory
and renormalization and gauge Symmetry
and the spin statistics theorem and
unlike book one I can't do all of the
equations I mean book one we we zip
through some equations but there was
nothing missing it was all there and the
amount of material being covered in book
two is just far too jaw humongous to do
that it would be three times the length
and much more intricacy if I did it all
in book two so I need to judiciously
choose which equations to go through and
where to wave hands and you know so far
I've been airing on the side of showing
some equations like I want to you can
see using the equations why the photon
is massless why charge is conserved
things like like that right I'm going to
Define what a non-abelian symmetry group
is you're going to know what SO3 and su3
stand for why they appear in different
equations and you're not you're not
going to go through everything so I'm
not talking about Spinners and the
direct way of constructing the electron
field and direct matrices and stuff like
that so I can skip over some things but
there's a lot there and it adds up to a
quite a bit of Demand on the reader but
I think it's an absolutely unique payoff
I don't think that any other book does
this the effective field Theory stuff
the gauge Theory stuff and so forth so I
really want to have a book where even if
it is a challenge for most people to
read there's a reward there's it's it's
useful to go through this I mean those
of you who have gone through the videos
for the biggest ideas in the universe
series know what I'm talking about you
know I did very similar things there and
we got pretty deep into the weeds but I
think that it's all worth it anyway
that's what's going through my brain
right now these days I mean the uh the
home stretch in finishing that book and
I I think you never know I gotta you
know take a break from it after I'm done
the first draft or the it's not the
first draft by any means but the draft
that I will hand in take a break from it
and then you know a little while later I
will come back read through the whole
thing start editing it and we'll see
what I think of how it's going
um the only other thing I want to say
this being the ask me anything Edition
is I really should remind people some of
the rules of the AMA you know uh for one
thing of course we know that the
questions are asked by patreon
supporters if you're out there and
you're listening and you enjoy this you
could be a patreon supporter even if you
don't want to ask questions that's fine
the number of people who ask questions
is much smaller than the total number of
patreon supporters there's just you know
a feeling of good fellowship and
happiness and warmth by being a patreon
supporter of mindscape so you could
shouldn't be such a supporter by going
to
www.patreon.com Sean M Carroll throw in
a dollar or two or whatever for every
episode it's not really that painful and
for those of you who are asking the
questions
um you know you know that I give
instructions at the beginning of every
post where I ask for the questions and
I've noticed that the instructions are
kind of being ignored a little bit by
some people and perhaps the two most
important instructions are keep the
questions short and you only get one
question and having like three or four
or five question marks in in a single
paragraph doesn't really count as one
question that's actually multiple
questions so you know I usually just try
to edit them down but if the questions
are too long then I'm not even going to
contemplate including them because we
can't include every question and if one
question is very very long that's an
easy way for me to decide to ignore it
so that's advice if you're out there
contributing questions to the AMA and
wondering why yours are not picked but
having said that most people are very
good about obeying the rules and I do
appreciate it we have a lot of good
questions this month so let's go
[Music]
our first question comes from Sid Huff
who says most universities in the U.S
Canada and some other countries have
instituted a 10-year system well
originally designed to provide academic
freedom to protect academics from social
or political backlash against their
research or ideas nowadays the original
rationale for 10 years seems
questionable in light of other civil and
criminal protections the law provides
critics argue the tenure May induce
post-tenure laziness top universities in
other countries survive nicely without
any tenure system at all what is your
view of the worth of the 10-year system
would you support getting rid of it no I
would absolutely not support getting rid
of it for many reasons and I say this by
the way as someone who does not have
tenure and never will have tenure most
likely the job I have right now you know
is permanent and they're not going to
fire me so maybe effectively it's like
having tenure but by the letter of the
law because I have this Homewood
Professor job at Johns Hopkins that
floats above any individual departments
without being a tenured member of any
individual department and therefore
being beholden to serve on all the
Committees that the Departments have I
have a better than 10-year job in many
ways but anyway I don't technically have
it and yet I'm super duper in favor of
it for one thing it does still provide
protections against
um attacks on freedom of speech and
things like that because it's not the
same thing academic freedom and the
government protected speech that you
have those are two different things and
sometimes one can protect certain kinds
of things and not the others you know
people can say really terrible things in
their social media and not be fired from
their job as a professor and I think
that's the right thing to do if that
speech that is very terrible even if
they're a terrible terrible terrible
person if it is not affecting their jobs
I don't think that tenure is or should
be an absolute ban against losing your
job if you do things like sexually
harass your undergraduates or commit
criminal Acts or start teaching
astrology in your astronomy classes
things like that there's all sorts of
reasons why you still can be fired from
your job even though you have tenure but
you should not be able to be fired from
your job just because of opinions that
you hold and how you express those
opinions outside of the University
context that is a stronger and different
kind of protection than you get just
from the First Amendment let's say here
in the United States and of course it
protects your right to do research in
various ways as well you're not pushed
around by the university ultimately you
get to decide what kind of research it
is you're doing but the other thing that
I think is very very underappreciated by
non-academics is that tenure makes
professors much cheaper you know there's
a lot of people who want to become
professors the number of people who get
phds and hope to become professors is
much larger than the number of actual
professorship jobs what is it that makes
being a professor such a good job well
you know there's various things Academia
is fun you know uh the intellectual
challenge of it all and so forth but
given all the training that you have as
a typical academic given the skills that
you have it is typically very easy to
earn not necessarily 100 possible but
typically easy to earn way more money in
the private sector than by being a
professor and one of the reasons why
people want to be professors anyway is
because it's a different kind of life
than you have in the private sector good
professors work extremely hard you know
they work weekends and Summers and
nights and the whole bit but they do it
not because they are being forced to buy
their bosses they are sort of
self-motivated people they want to get
this research done you know teach class
as well Etc
not everybody does it not everyone is
that motivated there's plenty of lazy
professors out there who don't work that
hard but many many many people do and
there's a feeling that there's a bargain
that is implicitly struck where I will
take less money for this job in return
for the job security provided by tenure
uh almost all academics in CIS in
countries that have tenure are in favor
of expanding it not getting rid of it
the academics in other countries that
you mentioned where tenure is not there
are often very very upset that there is
not tenure uh that's one reason why the
United States has historically been able
to attract people from other countries
and vice versa doesn't happen very often
when it comes to professorships uh when
I was you know leaving Caltech and I was
being I was talking to various places
other universities that might have in
principle been interested in hiring me
um that was an absolute consideration
you know the lack of 10 tenure even
though I didn't think I was going to get
fired or anything like that I think that
it shows a misunderstanding of the
academic system even though the academic
system is very far from perfect we
should aspire to be a system where we
let people think and do research without
worrying about their job security it
saves University's money it's good for
the well-being and mental health of the
professors and I think that that's
that's the best system that we have
right now now again there are people who
just get tenure and then stop doing
their work become lazy Etc there should
be other incentives for people like that
and there are guess what you know your
salary doesn't go up as fast if you're
not doing your job you don't get raises
and things like that there are people
who are
rather up there in age who never made
full Professor or the still associate
professors and things like that for one
reason or another you don't get perks
whatever it is uh funding for grad
students or for travel or whatever
there's various ways that the university
has of indicating its displeasure with
your work as a professor and that's why
you know the research
product productivity of the faculty in
the United States universities is
unprecedentedly high it's actually a
very good system not perfect but I still
think it's the best one I know of
someone whose handle is R then vln that
stands for something probably says
if a pair of spin entangled particles
Traverse separated paths through curved
space What happens to the directions of
their spins
so this is referring of course to a
version of the famous epr thought
experiment where you have two spins that
are entangled with each other and let's
say they're entangled in the sense that
they are opposite spinning so you don't
know which measurement outcome you're
going to get for either spin but you
know that when you do both of them they
will both be opposite and that's
supposed to be true even if they're very
very far away so the question quite
correctly points to this idea of the
spins being opposite what does that mean
that the spins are opposites if the
spins are located at different locations
in the space when the space in between
them is curved it is a feature of
Relativity of curved space time that
there's no unique way of comparing
vectors like spins at different
locations in curved space uniquely you
can what you can do uh sorry let me just
say that again so it sinks in before you
get the answer
if you what we're very used to taking
vectors like velocities or momentum or
things like that and adding them and
subtracting them that's what vectors are
supposed to be able to be done but in
general relativity in a curved
space-time background you really can't
do that there's no unique way to do that
it's true that you have vectors but
vectors are always defined as living at
a point there's even a whole bunch of
technical jargon that goes with this you
have the tangent space of the manifold
at each point and the vector lives in a
certain tangent space it lives in the
tangent space located at that point
point and there's no unique way of
comparing vectors at one point in space
time to vectors at another point in
space time there are sometimes
situations where you can sort of
approximately talk about such
comparisons like when we talk about the
apparent velocity of a distant Galaxy
right that is a very apparent velocity
where we know we're really cheating when
we talk about that but it kind of makes
sense and unless you really care about
the subtleties you don't need to be more
specific than that but in something like
the epr experiment where you say okay
I'm going to compare the spin outcomes
of entangled particles how are we to do
that and the answer is that even though
there is no unique way to compare
vectors at different points in
space-time if you give me a certain path
between two points in space time then I
can do my best to keep the spins
constant that is called parallel
transport to keep the vector constant as
I move along the path it's called
parallel transport you can read about it
in volume one of the biggest ideas in
the universe and so that is what will
happen some version of that depending on
what kind of spin you're moving around
will happen as you move a spin without
literally pushing its direction of
motion if you just sort of do your best
to keep it constant as you go from one
point to another in space time when the
two entangled particles are created
they're at the same point right that is
a feature laws of physics they are local
when you have entangled these particles
in the right way something started at
one point in space time and then spread
to different points and you just have to
tell me exactly what path that traveling
happened on and then I can figure out
what the relative spins would be and
what the prediction for measuring them
should be
Stevie CPW says when he was in his early
teens my brother told my devoutly
Christian mother that he was an atheist
and it made her very sad it took me
longer to transition to atheism and then
to declare it but it was still hard for
my mother to take when I did
when did you realize you were an atheist
how long did it take for you to declare
it to your parents and what was their
reaction also what advice do you have
for people who want to come out of the
atheist closet but are concerned about
disappointing or hurting their religious
loved ones
well this is It's a complicated question
because it's going to depend very much
on your individual situation I don't
think there's any one size fits-all
answer to questions like this it's part
of an issue involving the relationship
that you already have along many
dimensions between yourself and your
parents you know my parents were
religious but not that religious that
was not Central to their life in any way
so there wasn't any Grand reveal of my
atheism or anything like that it just
sort of crept up and became clear and it
never became a big deal but that doesn't
mean that it's not a big deal to other
people as with many other ways in which
you could come out right come out about
many things most most famously I suppose
about being gay or being trans or being
something like that it's actually quite
analogous you know hopefully in all of
these cases your family will be mature
enough and loving enough to support
whatever choices you have and it is your
on your side the responsibility is to to
be as understanding and loving about
their feelings as you can you know you
should stick by your guns when it comes
to believing whatever it is you believe
about the universe but the fact that
they can be upset by it is real and you
can hope that you don't
um upset them right or you could at
least say I know I'm going to be
upsetting but I want to do it in the
gentlest way possible and you know
hopefully the fact that you are members
of the same family and care about each
other is more important than your
attitudes towards atheism and theism and
things like that look sometimes it's not
sometimes people have to uh cut off
contact with their family because they
disagree about something pretty profound
I think that's also okay I'm not someone
who thinks that just because you have
family members means you have to put up
with anything that they do no matter how
terrible it is and they should accept
you for who you are you have to maybe
let's put it this way you have to read
respect them enough
to imagine that they will eventually
accept you for who you are and to try to
give them whatever space and time they
need to do that
okay I'm going to group a bunch of
questions together there were a bunch of
questions that were engendered by the
recent podcast we had with Thomas hertog
and I'm going to try to read several of
them but there are even others that I'm
not going to read because it's all along
the same basic ideas
says the conversation with Thomas hertog
inspired me to read his book which was
very interesting however although he
emphasized that this top-down principle
which was used to deduce the previous
history of the universe differed from
the anthropic principle I did not see
the distinction can you perhaps clarify
what the difference is
Bruno Tashara says I'm not sure I was
able to understand Thomas hertog's
Quantum cosmology what struck me with me
was something like the distant past and
future space are uncertain but what
causes the decoherence of the near time
in space is it us
Nick Gall says what's the difference
between your Multiverse cosmology and
hockey and hertog's top-down worm's eye
holographic cosmology I had difficulty
understanding the details on how the two
differ from your podcast with her talk
and then uh red Antonov says can you
clarify what Thomas hertog was driving
at in the quantum cosmology episode so I
mean clearly there was something that
was unclear about that episode sorry
about that but we'll try our best uh
anyway rad continues was he saying that
at the largest scales the correct theory
is one that calculates probability
amplitudes just like quantum mechanics
does at the microscopic scale thus what
we observe with our telescope is one of
many possible outcomes albeit each
having a different likelihood can the
theory like this be tested does it have
anything to say about dark energy or
predictive effect akin to Dark Matter so
I will confess that I've glanced through
the hertogen and Hawking technical
papers here but I've not read them in in
great detail I do think I have the basic
idea of what's going on or at least I
understand what I take to be the most
important underlying issue so let me try
to explain that maybe it will shed some
light on what is going on so think back
we were just talking about Alice and Bob
and they're I don't think I said Alice
and Bob we were talking about the epr
experiment right with two different
spins very far away uh there's an
implicit thing going on in how we
usually talk about the epr experiment
which is we have two particles they're
entangled we move them far away we
measure one and then in the many worlds
way of talking we say decoherence
happens and the branch the wave function
branches and there's a branching into
one branch where Alice observes spin up
Bob observes spin down and another where
Alice was observed spin down Bob
observes spin up but as we said with
general relativity there is a little bit
of an ambiguity as to how you compare
what you mean by the direction of spins
at different points in in space you know
the amount of curve space time between
us and Alpha Centauri is actually not
that large it's still pretty close to
Flat space time so in practice this is
not really a worry but in cosmology it
becomes more of a worry so one looming
issue in many worlds quantum mechanics
that people disagree about is how the
branching of the wave function extends
to throughout space and time let's put
it that way
um David Wallace in his former mindscape
guest uh in his book uh the emergent
Multiverse talks about a picture where
what happens is you make a Quantum
measurement at some point in space-time
and then in your future light cone there
are two branches but outside your future
light cone there are not two branches
there's still just one branch of the of
the wave function of the universe just
as there was before you did the
measurement at all so somehow there's
this interplay between space-time
location and branching that is actually
not the way that I like to think about
it I like to just let the universe
Branch throughout space time all at once
and this looks like it's violating
special relativity but it's not really
because as I often say space time lives
within the branches it's not that the
branches live within space time so what
is this what does this all have to do
with uh hertog and Hawking they are
dealing with a situation where they have
a wave function of the universe they are
truly Quantum from the start okay it's
not supposed to be a semi-classical
space time with Quantum fields in it
like many physicists often think about
it's truly a quantum mechanical story of
space-time itself so here I am in my
location in space time I make some
measurements I look around I see that
things are located in certain places so
what I've done is I have decohered and
branched the wave function and now I am
on a branch with a certain
semi-classical arrangement of stuff
around me that makes sense okay the
question is how do I extend that Branch
out to the edge of the universe out to
the edge of the observable universe and
Beyond it okay there's no Edge to the
universe but there is an edge to The
Observer universe and how do I extend my
semi-classical branch
in fact it's perfectly okay to extend
that Branch out to the edge of the
observable universe because after all it
is observable you're looking at the
positions of galaxies and the
temperature of the cosmic microwave
background all of this branches the wave
function causes D coherence Etc
but what about extending it past the
Horizon of the observable universe
that's a much dicier thing it's much
less clear how we should extend our
Branch into regions of the universe that
we're not observing and therefore not
Deco hearing and collapsing and
branching Etc so what I think is going
on in in I've translated into my
language so maybe Thomas wouldn't
actually even agree with me but the way
that I think about it is
um they're emphasizing the fact that
outside your observable part of the
universe the universe is still
inelectably Quantum in nature there's no
such thing as the classical state of the
universe outside the part of it that you
can observe you should just talk about
the whole wave function all at once and
of course even at one location or what
we would think of as one location there
are many branches going on with many
different kinds of observers so what
they're really doing is try trying to
zoom in on what is the regime of the
wave function where it consistently
makes sense to talk about a
semi-classical universe that has
observers in it and things like that and
there may be many many such regions many
many is physics talk for a huge number
maybe an infinite number of regions with
different kinds of observers seeing
different things so it's a different
picture than the traditional
cosmological Multiverse the traditional
cosmological Multiverse as you know is
different from the everedian Multiverse
they have ready Multiverse as when I
observe a spin right here in the room
there's now well I shouldn't say right
here in the room but right here I have
caused to come into existence two
different branches of the wave function
whereas the traditional cosmological
Multiverse has a single semi-classical
space-time spread throughout a distance
much much larger than what we can
observe and I think they're calling that
ladder picture into question that you
shouldn't talk about the actual
semi-classical space time that we live
in outside our observable universe you
should talk about the quantumness of it
all so but nevertheless
I think it would be fair to argue that
still for all intents and purposes you
have something that is very very much
like a Multiverse maybe you're not
locating uh different universes and
different legitimate physical locations
because you're not into classical space
time when you go outside what we can
observe but there are still different
observers maybe some of them see
different laws of physics certainly some
of them see different physical
conditions about
the energy density the amount of Dark
Matter things like that okay so that's
my general picture of what's going on
and I'm not at all sure that it's right
or that it makes sense or anything like
that it might be I'm very much in favor
of
um taking seriously the quantum nature
of the whole universe you know similar
words were said before by
um Raphael buso and Lenny suskind and
also yasunuri nomura in a bunch of
papers from a few years ago asking
whether or not in a world with
holography and complementarity many
worlds and the cosmological Multiverse
aren't secretly the same thing so I
think that these are all really good
issues that uh should be thought of very
very carefully and I think that uh
hockey and her talk have an angle on
them I I don't know whether it's the
right angle just because I haven't
thought of it thought through it too
quickly final note on that to go to Red
antonov's question can a theory like
this have anything to say about dark
energy or predict an effect akin to dark
matter you know for dark matter the
answer is clearly no and and I would
dissuade you from trying to think of
weird physical effects that have an
effect akin to Dark Matter it is
overwhelmingly likely that dark matter
is just matter of some sort it it looks
like a particle it acts like a particle
it walks like a particle it quacks like
a particle by which we mean you know it
has an energy density that evolves with
time just like particles do it changes
its spatial location and density just
like cold particles would and so on and
so on we don't know what particle it is
but I wouldn't look to weird physical
effects to be dark matter I would look
to new particles to be dark matter as
opposed to uh as as concerned saying
something about Dark Energy you know
famously
one of the best successes of the
something like the anthropic principle
was accounting for the fact that the
dark energy density the cosmological
constant that we observe is much smaller
than what you might might naively
predict I presume that uh Hawking and
hertog would claim that kind of success
for their own model but I don't I
haven't actually seen them explicitly do
it
okay
rollover Jess says I think that you
describe yourself as a human about laws
of nature contemporary contemporary
humanism was set out by David Lewis as
regarding the world as a vast Mosaic of
local matters of particular fact just
one little thing than another
so by the way this is Sean talking now
not Rolo
um yeah humanism in this sense about
laws of physics is laws of physics are
just convenient descriptions summaries
of the set of the infinite number of
events that actually happen in the world
as opposed to
um the idea that laws of physics have a
separate existence and have some oomph
they help bring about the actual
physical configuration of reality okay
the question continues surely modern
physics views the world as various types
of fields described by a lagrangian
which vary continuously the value of the
field at a given point is completely not
independent of the valued neighboring
points isn't this a modal structure
constraining matters a particular fact
I.E exactly what the human denies unless
you say the fields might have taken any
value but just happen to take values
described by continuously varying
functions which seems insanely
improbable
so there's two things going on here one
is a physics issue and one is a
philosophy issue the physics issue is it
is not true to say that modern physics
views the world as various types of
fields which vary continuously that
would be true if the world were
described by a classical field Theory
but it is not it is described as far as
We Know by Quantum field theories maybe
not even that when it comes to gravity
but certainly the fields that we're
looking at are quantum and these ideas
of continuity
um only makes sense if you think that
the field has definite values at
different points in space but Quantum
Fields don't they have wave functions
okay so you can't just think of it as
smooth Fields rather than ones that are
that have discontinuities all over the
place in fact there's a this is not
exactly the same point but there's an
important point to keep in mind if you
know about the feynman's sum over
histories the path integral take on
quantum mechanics where you say say that
in quantum mechanics or in Quantum field
Theory you derive the amplitude to go
from some initial condition to some
final condition by summing over e to the
is where s is the action summing over
every single possible path that takes
you from the initial state to the final
State and you can prove mathematically
that the set of smooth paths that take
you from the initial state to the final
state are a set of measure zero
they contribute nothing to the path
integral all of the work in the path
integral is being done by
pads that are discontinuous everywhere
so this is not a statement about field
Theory but it is just a reminder the
things that you would have taken for
granted being smooth In classical
mechanics are not always smooth in
quantum mechanics
so the
more philosophical point is I think that
you're making sort of a I think I think
it's a mistake but anyway let me say it
as a presumption that many non-humans
often do which is they attribute some
element of surprisingness or
improbability to the fact that the world
obeys the laws of physics so I could say
everything that you said in principle in
the context of classical mechanics of
Point particles moving on trajectories
right if I thought that Newton had been
correct and I thought that the Earth and
the Sun you know had equations of motion
that were perfectly classical and they
had trajectories
in the space of all trajectories that
the Earth could take around the Sun
the set of trajectories that are smooth
and continuous is a set of measure zero
but the but that's what the actuals one
that it seems to take according to
Newtonian laws of physics so one is
tempted to say that would seem insanely
improbable but that's only because you
are somehow attributing some probability
distribution to the measure on the space
of possible paths that you made some
choice about what to be surprised about
but there's no principle that anyone has
ever advocated in favor of that says
that every imaginable path is a priori
equally likely and we should be
surprised when the universe obeys
certain patterns and not others I mean
you can you can worry about it you can
ask the question but you have to realize
that it is a question it's not some
pre-existing result that we should rely
on that says that if it weren't for laws
of physics all sorts of crazy behaviors
would in some sense be equally probable
what does that mean probable where did
this probability the function come from
it is a fact that the Universe obeys
patterns which which implies that its
Evolution uh in the real world describes
a very very very tiny and special subset
of all conceivable Evolutions that it
could now it's true that the anti-human
has an explanation for that namely that
there are laws of physics that force it
to do that but the human says you
haven't really explained anything by
saying that you just restated it do you
haven't you know how do these laws of
physics govern how do they actually
exert an influence is it like the
particles in the fields are trying to do
something and the laws of physics step
in and prevent them from doing it this
just seems like a bad anthropomorphic
analogy not an actual amount of insight
so you can choose to believe whichever
one you want but I think that both of
those positions make sense on their own
terms
Rue Phillips says what do you see as the
connection between large language models
and emergence what interests you about
it if anything for example the opening
statement of a recent research paper
States we present evidence that language
models can learn meaning despite being
trained only to perform next token
prediction on text specifically a corpus
of programs
well I think I think that your question
ends up in a place different than it
began I mean there's a this question
what is the connection between large
language models and emergence but then
there's the specific example from the
paper you quote now I would put those
two things on very different
um uh footings I have seen talks and
I've looked at papers claiming that
large language models exhibit some
understanding that they have not just an
ability to predict the next word or
sentence or whatever but they actually
attach some meaningfulness to it but
when you look closely at these talks in
these papers there they fall apart
they're just not that
um convincing they're defining what they
mean in such a narrow way as that it's
really not what you and I mean when we
think about meaning and extrapolation
Etc
um so I think that I'm not moved in what
I've seen so far uh by the idea that
these large language models are actually
not just learning what to say next but
learning what things mean or more
specifically that they are implicitly
forming a picture of the world in their
minds I don't want to say brains but you
know in in their minds well the way that
we think of human reasoning is that we
have a picture of the world right we
have a model of the world and so when
you say uh construct a a typical thing
that you ask large language models to do
is here are five objects you know a
table a box
um a coffee cup a marshmallow and a
pencil
stack them on top of each other in a way
that is the most stable and they're
pretty good at that actually right and
you say oh my goodness somehow they must
have a model of what is stable and what
is not stable no they don't what they
know is that lots of people have talked
about putting boxes on tables and very
few people have talked about putting
tables on boxes that's what they know so
I'm I I
think that there is the evidence that
any of this is actually happening in
large language models any of this
construction of a model of the world is
very very flimsy and in almost all these
cases you can then try a little bit
harder to make the llm say something
nonsensical and it's not that hard to
make them say something nonsensical
again that doesn't mean that I'm not
enormously impressed with what they do
but let's be accurate about what they do
so
having said all that your very first
question what is the connection between
large language models and emergence
um I'm not quite sure you mean I I'm not
sure if you're defining emergence as
something like what we just talked about
do you mean the emergence of meaning
somehow
um that's not what I usually mean when I
talk about emergence so I'm not sure
what what the connection might be I
don't generally try to attribute such a
connection but maybe there is one that
I'm just not aware of
I have been struggling with the
following question unitarity is a
foundational principle of quantum
theories it implies the preservation of
information and determinism the last two
principles imply time Symmetry and yet
time symmetry is broken in the weak
sector of the standard model and has to
be saved by CPT symmetry I know that CPT
symmetry arises naturally from the Dirac
equation I'm not implying it as ad hoc I
just can't reconcile the principles
above with results from experiments is
my reasoning flawed am I missing
something or does this indicate the
quantum theory is just not complete it
does not indicate the quantum theory is
not complete these are you know
perfectly good questions to ask but we
know the answers to these questions 100
perfectly well the basic answer is that
once you have reversibility
um which you get from unitarity that is
to say if you know the state of the
system at one point in time you can
uniquely predict what will be at another
point in time so that applies to quantum
mechanics as long as you don't measure
you don't collapse the wave function Etc
just the Schrodinger equation has that
feature then you can show that there
must be some definition of time reversal
invariance okay in the following sense
that you have your state you can evolve
It Forward in time do some
transformation to it to the Future
um
call that the time reversal operator
then
evolve it backward in time to where you
started apply that time reversal
operator again and you will come back to
where you started so there's four things
you did you fall forward time reversal
evolve Back Time reversal again come
back to where you started such a Time
reversal operator will always exist if
the Dynamics are reversible if they're
not reversible so you know think about
Bill your balls on a table but I put
glue on all the bumpers so all the bill
your balls bang around but when they hit
a bumper they just stick there that is
not reversible Dynamics and from knowing
what the state is in the future I cannot
predict what the state was in the past
likewise if wave functions truly
collapse in quantum mechanics
so but what the this theorem set does
not say is that you know what time
reversal is
um time reversal is often involves some
massaging of the states and that's
that's true Just In classical mechanics
you know
um think about positions and momentum in
the hamiltonian version of of classical
mechanics your phase space is positions
and momentum and there is no a priori
relationship between velocity and
momentum that turns out to be an
equation of motion but the fundamental
variables are independent of each other
and they are position and momentum and
guess what to get time reversal you keep
the positions fixed but you reverse all
the momenta right so that was a choice
that you made reversing all the momenta
was a non-trivial thing that you did
likewise in quantum mechanics uh you can
do the same thing but you need to take
the complex conjugate of the wave
function as part of your time reversal
operation
So when you say
um in the standard model time symmetry
has to be saved by CPT I don't think
that's the right way to think about it I
would say time symmetry is CPT CPT which
is charge parity and naive time reversal
invariance is just what you should mean
by the time reversal and variance of the
standard model it involves C and P as
well as the naive complex conjugation
operation there's nothing wrong or
surprising or weird about that it's a
hundred percent compatible with
unitarity the Schrodinger equation
Etc
David Maxwell says for the first 40
years of my life I adored science and
dismissed philosophy as the musings of
ancients devoid irrelevance you bridge
that gap for me by revealing over years
of mindscape that a lot of what I love
is actually a philosophy I just didn't
know how to call it that I've come to
think of them as two sides of the same
coin each the application of logic to
gain Insight but one applies to the
testable the others to the other to the
untestable science has become cool and
interest in it widespread basic
scientific literacy is widely thought of
as useful to life yet philosophy is
thought of as a niche area of little
relevance outside its own academic
bubble as someone who's indirectly
bridged that gap for me how you wouldn't
how would you encourage the reframing
and marketing of philosophy to new
generations so that it can one day be as
cool and ubiquitous as science has
become
well that's a very good question you
know I also I'm not sure if there are
two sides of the same coin but I see
them as continuous with each other
science and philosophy they're both ways
of trying to understand our world that
use slightly different tool kits but
have the same ultimate goal in each
subset there are different problems that
are considered to be Central and most
important but but that's okay there's a
lot of overlap where they have common
problems like what happens when the wave
function collapses in in quantum
mechanics
um
I'm not I don't know if I have an
accurate data based statement to make
about popular philosophy I'm not as
familiar with that as popular science
um clearly you know we teach science in
high school and Junior High School in a
way that we don't teach philosophy here
in the United States I never had a
philosophy class until I was in
university I know that in other
countries they do teach philosophy much
earlier and that's an interesting fact
why here in the United States we're
relatively slow to start people learning
about philosophy but then outside of the
context of and by the way I also don't
know what fraction of college
undergraduates take a philosophy course
I would hope it's large but I somehow
suspect that maybe it's not anyway
um in addition to within the school
systems there's also the question of
just in general life how ubiquitous is
philosophy how easy is it to find a good
popular philosophy book on the
bookshelves there's certainly lots of
books that kind of
seen quasi-philosophical meaning of life
self-help books those kinds of things
and there are books that are actually
quite respectable by people like former
mindscape guests like David Chalmers or
Daniel Dennett and so forth that are
very readable to the outside but it's
nothing like the popular science
Industry which is much more successful
and much more ubiquitous so I think I
mean let's turn it around this is a
market opportunity I think that there's
a lot that can be done to share the
Delights of good philosophy with a much
wider audience and part of that is that
just like scientists
philosophers will have to learn the
difference between what they do in their
everyday research Endeavors versus what
is interesting to the outside world
right scientists have to recognize that
that's true you can't use the same
jargon or even necessarily came about to
care about the same puzzles when you
talk to a general audience but some of
the stuff that you do is interesting and
likewise for philosophy some of the
stuff that philosophers do is absolutely
interesting uh to a wider audience and
there have been examples of you know
very successful popular philosophy that
that the novel Sophie's World for
example was very popular not too long
ago and
Harry Frankfurter wrote this book
that sold a tremendous number
of copies so it absolutely can be done
um and I'm kind of just hopeful that
philosophers try harder to do it you
know they are they're a little less
motivated because they don't get that
much funding from the government right
there's no large Grant proposals there's
no large experiments that need to be
funded that that philosophers can
motivate their colleagues to reach out
to The Wider public because otherwise
their funding will have evaporated
because their funding is already
evaporated there's very little funding
in the field but nevertheless uh my my
take has always been
that if you spend your life
thinking about deep Mysteries of the
universe and then you
answer some deep mystery of the universe
or at least you know get some make some
progress gain some traction on learning
about the Deep Mysteries of the universe
and then you don't tell anybody that's
just bizarre or you only tell your 12
friends who read your paper right I mean
I I think that as not as an individual
because individuals have different
um skill sets different interests and
whatever but as a field it's perfectly
clear to me that philosophy should care
much more than it does about spreading
the message of what is going on and the
cool stuff that they they think about to
a much broader audience
um I I have no institutional influence
over these things but I can try to set
an example I can try to write books and
do podcasts and give talks in which
philosophy and science are intertwined
with each other until eventually people
catch on like perhaps David you have
that this is all smart people trying to
understand the universe a little bit
better and it's all worth following and
thinking about
Michael pickle says after listening to
the latest episode regarding the
offshore Financial system as a complex
system I'm curious about the stability
of complexity in general some complex
systems such as life for the brain or
the entire world of Offshore Banking
seem to have error correction and
stability enhancing measures
Incorporated whereas some systems such
as the Venture Finance banking system
that is teetering in Silicon Valley at
the moment seem to lack some important
inbuilt error correction mechanisms in
your opinion does complexity
fundamentally include instability and
the possibility of system collapse or is
a system's overall stability even
without additional error correction
mechanisms more case and fact specific
I love this question in part because I
don't know the full answer I don't have
a full theory of this but my vague
impression is that you're going to have
both in other words
a complex system that that has any
non-trivial lifetime at all that that
exists over
um well thinking as a physicist you
would say there's some dynamical time
scale right there's for any given system
there's some time scale it takes for the
system to change in an order one way and
if a complex system lasts for many
dynamical time scales it's going to have
to have some stability mechanisms some
negative feedback mechanisms where if it
begins to get out of alignment something
nudges it back into alignment but at the
same time most complex systems I think
are going to have failure modes
um are either going to have fluctuations
that can grow or they will have life
spans built into them after all living
organisms are not designed to last
forever for the most part some of them
are but the ones that are tend to be the
simple ones like a bacteria will not a
back ethereum will not die of old age
okay but it's a single celled organism
it's not that complex the greater
complex systems
um maybe require some input from the
outside world in order to do that error
correction they require some food right
some free energy that they can use to
repair themselves and keep going and
maybe this is a process that isn't going
to last forever
um and of course there are very very
ephemeral things that are temporarily
complex and then go away and maybe
something like
a startup company or something like that
or the junk bond system or something
like that qualify under those criteria
so I think there's probably a rich
landscape out there of different things
going on it's probably not a simple
answer you're probably going to need
some error correction stability negative
feedback loops there somewhere but
they're never going to be
guaranteed to last forever it would be a
fun thing to study more in detail
Ahmad Shaker says how exactly do you get
from entropy increases in a closed
system an entropy was lower in the past
to this explains the era of time surely
these events are correlated but how do
we know they're actually related
yeah I mean we don't know apriari
they're related we do work to show that
they are related so there's a way of
talking about the arrow of time that is
sometimes popular in which people talk
about many different arrows of time
right there's the thermodynamic Arrow of
time there's the Aging Arrow of time
there's the arrow of memory there's the
electromagnetic Arrow time whatever you
want different kinds of arrows and then
you would like to ask why they are
related to each other and if they are
related to each other my own personal
way of talking is there's one
fundamental underlying Arrow of time
which is the thermodynamic Arrow the
fact that entropy is increasing and then
other arrows that we know about are
parasitic on that they are they arise
because of that one so the fact that we
remember the past not the future the
fact that we age the fact that causes
come before effects these are all
because entropy is increasing I'm not
actually going to answer the question
because connecting those things
explaining why for example increasing
entropy is behind the fact that we
remember the past but not the future is
work you know that's that's stuff that I
talk about at Great length in my book
from eternity to here and it's ongoing
work we don't know all the answers to
all those questions so
um it is absolutely something you need
to do the effort put in the effort to
establish that it's true it's not
automatic but I think that the effort
has been put in at least enough to say
that it's going to be true even if not
all of the eyes are yet dotted and the
t's are yet crossed
Eric davichi says when matter collapses
into a black hole does it have to
overcome the Pali Exclusion Principle to
expand on the question what happens to
the various parts of an atom when they
get smushed down into the singularity at
what point is a quark dequarkified
well I think that there's a lot going on
here and part of the answer is going to
be there aren't any singularities in
nature you know Singularity is a
prediction of classical general
relativity but classical general
relativity is not right because it's not
Quantum and in particular you're asking
a question here about the quantum
behavior of matter so even at the level
of the behavior of quantum fields in a
classical space time you can't quite
invoke the penalty Exclusion Principle
because you really should be talking
about Fields not particles right now
there are fermionic Fields there are the
fields that make up electrons and
neutrinos and things like that that obey
a field version of the penalty Exclusion
Principle but what you would expect is
that even though you squeeze particles
into the same position in space that
they're not in the same Quantum State
because they're vibrating or they have
different momentum in different ways so
when the palette exclusion principle
really says what it says is not that you
can't put two particles at the same
point in space but you can't put them in
the same Quantum state so in principle
in a Quantum field you could always just
excite it and give it different momenta
and fit in a lot of particles into a
tiny region of space but again the real
answer is questions like this involve
quantum gravity if you want to discuss
what happens in the real world and we
don't understand quantum gravity yet
enough to give you the correct
description of what happens at that
point in your the near the point in a
black hole where you would have had a
singularity of classical general
relativity had been correct
Brendan says are you a fan of the John
Wick movies or are those type of movies
not interesting to you
I am a fan this I have no objection to
those type of movies I'm very happy to
have fun action movies that are not
trying to be
to I don't know intellectual or whatever
but you know the the idea of an
intellectual movie is a slippery one I
think the original John Wick movie was
brilliant I thought that it was a fresh
take on a very old genre which is very
very hard to do
um it was good storytelling it started
small and then the world grew a little
bit the action sequences were novel and
different and interesting you know a lot
of these days in superhero movies or
whatever or spy movies or Thrillers
whatever I actually tune out during the
action sequences because I know the
hero's not going to die and you know I
know that the basic moves that are going
to happen so I wait for the plot to to
restart again but in the original John
Wick movie it was really very very well
done and interesting stunt choreography
in those action scenes I think the
subsequent movies in the series have not
been as good they sort of lost the focus
of the storytelling aspect it's become a
little bit uh bloated in the you know
the universe expands but it's not really
coherent you know in the in the first
John Wick movie there were hints at this
wider mythology and they were all
intriguing and you wanted to know more
why were these hotels there what kind of
Assassins are there uh but you didn't
need to know all of them for the purpose
of the story so the fact that you didn't
know didn't bother you in the later
in the sequels I suppose uh to me as
they showed you more and more of that
background it still doesn't make sense
but it should make more sense because
you're being shown more of it and it
doesn't and the most recent one which
people really raved about I just didn't
like it all I thought it was just boring
I was I was ready to leave honestly I
thought I really had lost the heart that
was at the center of um the original
movie like why are these things
happening it's clearly you know just an
excuse to get from one choreographed
action sequence to another so I think
the first one was a little bit of a
lightning in the bottle magical event
but it was hard to reproduce in later
installments
Axel spelled aksel says can we assume
that any particle is always being
observed by its interactive environment
so why would a detector be treated
differently or could it be that a
detector is breaking the environment
symmetry so no we cannot always assume
that a particle is being observed by its
interactive environment so there's two
things going on here that are very
important one is
for observation in the sense of a
quantum mechanical observation you know
quantum mechanical observation that
splits the wave function into different
possible observable
um eigenstates would be the technical
term in other words an observation that
entangles the system that you're looking
at with some measuring device you know
that's a specific kind of physical
interaction but it's not the only kind
the example I like to use is if I have a
spinning particle right if it's in a
superposition of spin up and spin down
and I drop it in a gravitational field
there's no question that the
gravitational field is interacting with
the particle it's pulling the particle
in the direction of increasing gravity
but it pulls the spin up and spin down
parts of the particle in exactly the
same way so it's not entangling it's not
measuring the spin of the particle so
particles are constantly interacting
with world around them but that doesn't
mean they're being observed in the
technical sense that we talk about
measurement in quantum mechanics the
other thing that's the first thing the
second thing is particles are tiny so an
individual particle is relatively easy
to shield from being observed by the
rest of the universe like we said it can
be interacting with the rest of the
universe it can be you know trapped in a
certain location in a crystal in some
sort of potential inside a solid or
something like that but it's not
interacting in a way that measures any
feature of it whereas when you have a
macroscopic system
um like a cat or a pointer of on a
device or something like that if you try
to put that into a superposition of two
different things with different
locations in space it's very very
difficult essentially impossible to
Shield it from being measured by its
environment that's why according to the
standard explanation of decoherence we
see in the real world things with
relatively localized positions in space
that need not be the case for a single
elementary particle because it's not
bumping into things and having its
position measured all the time
Walter E Miller says what is your
expectation for the next generation of
particle accelerators a more powerful
version of the LHC for proton smashing
or a completely different version
perhaps a muon or electron accelerator
what will physicists be probing for
I'm not going to say a lot about this
because I don't really have a lot to say
you know I I'm a huge supporter of
experimental elementary particle physics
I think we should build new particle
accelerators I don't know what they're
going to be I remember participating in
a Snowmass Workshop Snowmass is um a
kind of process it's literally a place
right in Colorado where you meet and you
I think it's Colorado anyway in the
Rocky Mountains where it's a ski resort
but in summer times on occasional years
particle physicists will get together
and map out the future of the field and
so this was when we'd already agreed
that the Large Hadron Collider was going
to be built but was 20 years ago so it's
like 2004 the LHC was going to come
online but we were thinking about what's
going to come next and everyone rallied
around the idea of building a linear
collider okay a uh a collider that would
take electrons and positrons or
something like that rather than protons
and neutrons rather than protons or
antiprotons so smashing them together at
very high energies but the thing is that
with a linear collider you can't reach
quite as high energies as you can with a
circular Collider
but you can get more Precision because
you can control with individual
electrons and positrons are doing in a
way that big protons smashing into each
other like at the LHC are a lot Messier
so the thought was the LHC would turn on
we would discover a bunch of new
particles and the LIC would be a
discovery machine and then the linear
collider would be a
studying machine learning about all
those new particles that we had
discovered at the LHC
as maybe you've heard we haven't found
that many new particles of the LHC we
found the Higgs boson and we refound the
standard model so far that's it so the
motivation for a linear collider has
diminished since then and we still don't
have a consensus 20 years later on what
collider we will build next or even if
we will build one
um probably the two most active areas of
of uh interest here are in China or are
at CERN once again in Europe for
building a Next Generation collider but
I am not up on what people's favorite
versions are I know that muon colliders
which are sort of like electrons but
heavier I've received a lot of recent
attention they can in some sense be a
Best of Both Worlds kind of thing where
you can get the Precision of an electron
but also the higher energy of a proton
the problem is buon's Decay you can't
keep them alive for very long so there's
special technical challenges there as
far as what they'll be looking for you
know they'll be happy to find anything
thing there's no more targets there were
targets for the LHC
and they didn't find them so now it's a
fishing Expedition but it's a good kind
of fishing Expedition it's you know
there's something out there it's be very
very very unlikely in my mind to think
that we've discovered all the particles
there are to discover what I can promise
you is that they're discoverable at any
particular new particle accelerator so
it's a cross your fingers and hope for
the best kind of situation
Prometheus says I understand that mass
and electric charge are two different
fundamental properties of particles but
as far as I know there are no massless
particles that have an electric charge
this makes me wonder if the electric
charge is somehow an intrinsic property
of the mass of a particle what is your
take on this
well you could imagine this this is a
good question it's fundamentally a
Quantum field Theory question because
the field theory-ness matters in this
case you really can't really think just
about individual particles the reason
why is the following if you have a
massive particle so forget about
electric charge for a second if you have
massive particle there's energy that you
associate with the particle and part of
that energy is its rest energy E equals
m c squared and part of it is its
kinetic energy if it's moving and in
relativity the relationship is that e
squared equals p squared plus M squared
where p is the momentum and we've set
speed of light equal to one so it's a
Pythagoras's Theorem kind of thing the
the total energy is the hypotenuse of
the mass and the momentum
so in that case there is a minimum
energy that is not zero the minimum
energy you can have is the mass as the
mass goes to zero the minimum energy
gets smaller and smaller and for
massless particles you can have
arbitrarily small amounts of energy okay
now if you consider charged particles
rather than neutral particles there's
always some energy there because there's
energy in the electric field around the
charged particle so I think that even
though I haven't thought about this you
should do it much more carefully I think
that if you have charged particles they
will always have at least a little bit
of mass but that might depend on details
of the quantum field Theory it might be
possible to build some Quantum field
Theory where you effectively have
massless charged particles I kind of
doubt it you could write it down and try
but I think that something would get in
the way of having the physical Mass
actually be zero
Tracy P says how is it that black holes
can grow if Observer is sufficiently far
away never see infalling objects cross
the Event Horizon I've heard answers to
this question that sidestep the issue by
using different coordinates Etc but the
black hole does the black hole only grow
in certain reference frames but not
others
no as black holes really do grow because
who cares what Observer is far away see
right what is the black hole see is the
much more relevant question also I mean
that's the that's the glib but correct
answer but there is a subtlety here that
it's worth remarking on when we talk
about what observers see when particles
fall into black hole black holes we very
often make an approximation which is
we imagine that the particles falling
into the black holes themselves have no
gravitational field
I don't mean by that a massless particle
because even massless particles have a
gravitational field they have some
energy so they have some gravity okay
um which actually makes me rethink the
answer to the previous question because
the gravitational field is kind of like
an electric field so maybe just like
there are massless particles with a
gravitational field there are also
massless particles that can be
electrically charged maybe I was wrong
about that one shows you what I know
anyway I'm not familiar with any viable
field theories that have electrically
charged massless particles but maybe
that's just because they don't appear in
nature so we don't try too hard to
construct them maybe they are possible
after all I'm talking myself into it
anyway
um the point is that real particles do
have their own gravitational field and
we ignore that when we talk about what
you see when you throw a particle into a
black hole so as a result when a real
particle falls into the black hole it
pulls on the black hole just like the
black hole pulls on it so what
physically happens and people have
actually thought about this is that the
event horizon of the black hole when the
in-falling particle comes close enough
to it that event horizon expands a
little bit because it's being pulled by
the particle and it sort of engulfs the
particle and eats it up and the result
is a slightly bigger black hole that
includes the mass and energy of the
particle itself so I think that um
from the point of view of the outside
Observer you would see the particle move
more and more slowly but eventually in
the real world you would see it
swallowed by the black hole it certainly
Drew one way or the other that the black
hole does grow
whether or not an observer sees it from
far away is not really the relevant
question
okay my mind is still thinking about
this massless charge particle question I
should I should actually think a little
bit before answering these questions in
in real time
um I still don't I'm not sure what the
answer is but let me say two other true
things that might be relevant one is
certainly it's possible to write down a
classical field theory that would
correspond to massless charged particles
my suspicion is that Quantum Effect 3
normalization virtual particles would
effectively give such particles Mass but
I don't know about that I'm not 100 sure
about that the other thing worth saying
is that there clearly are not massless
charged particles in the real world that
much is is perfectly clear because
they'd be very easy to create in Virtual
particles sorry uh interactions Etc we
could just you know bump any charged
particles in to each other and they
would spew out a very large number of
massless charged particles uh that
doesn't happen in the real world so it's
a completely hypothetical question which
is fine but just so I was not if I was
not clear about that there's no
lingering question that they exist in
the real world it's a purely question
about what we could hypothetically
imagine okay even if I have more
thoughts on it I'm not going to say
anything more that's enough to chew over
let's move on Brandon Lewis says I
sometimes wonder whether industrial
civilization might have Arisen on Earth
more than once in other words are we
sure ours is the first one given that
the evidence of previous civilizations
might have been wiped out in some
cataclysm what do you think
I think it is very very very very
unlikely that anything like that
happened
um it's fun to imagine that there were
previous industrial civilizations but
the I think that it's you would
underestimate the extent to which we
would imagine such a civilization would
leave its Mark like even if you got rid
of all of the literal physical artifacts
of our civilization we have also changed
the atmosphere and the geology of the
planet and and future scientists would
be able to recognize that right but also
you know historians and uh
archaeologists and paleontologists are
really remarkably good at figuring out
things about the evolution of life and
the evolution of civilization and things
like that it uh it doesn't seem to make
sense to me that you could literally
have a an advanced industrial
civilization that completely escaped our
notice the only way you could possibly
do it would be if it were completely
localized if there were like an advanced
industrial civilization that lived on an
island like Atlantis and then it
collapsed under the sea so it was really
uh it left a had a small impact on the
earth as a whole and then all of the
physical evidence was just hidden
forever I don't think that a single
Island could support the uh coming into
existence of an advanced civilization so
I'm not very worried about that and by
the way Atlantis is not real so that's
just a colorful analogy to what it would
have to be but I think the real answer
is it's very very very unlikely
Aaron C says I read recently that aleph
null is the set of all real numbers and
is called the smallest possible Infinity
this had me thinking about the sizes of
Infinities relative to each other and
there are a few things that I'm having
trouble wrapping my head around how
could there be a bound to how small or
how yeah how could there be a bound on
how small an Infinity could be couldn't
you just find an arbitrarily smaller
subset of all the real numbers for
example wouldn't the set of all prime
numbers be smaller than set of all real
numbers which leads me to the question
is there any real world physical
implication or utility to comparing the
different sizes of infinity
so there's a lot going on here
um as usual it's a longer than question
that it needs to be but that's okay I'll
just ramble on about a little bit so the
the first thing I want to say is
elephnol is not the number of real
numbers okay it's the number of integers
or the number of natural numbers but the
number of real numbers is a strictly
larger Infinity this was one of the
um discoveries by Georg Contour years
ago that there are different sizes of
infinity in the set of real numbers
which is the Continuum right the real
numbers are all the numbers including pi
and E and all those things square root
of two uh the integers are 0 1 2 3 minus
one minus two minus three Etc and Cantor
proved that the number of real numbers
is strictly larger than the number of
integers but Infinity is not a number in
the usual sense and so there are things
you can say about Infinity but they
don't always map on to things that we're
used to saying about non-infinite
numbers such as if you take the just
take the integers okay which which do
have a what we call a cardinality which
is the size of the set how many numbers
are there cardinality of the integers is
L if null
but you can take half of that set like
just take the even numbers right what is
the cardinality of that it is also
alephanol the size of the set all the
even numbers is equal it's not
approximately equal to it's exactly
equal to the size of the set all of the
integers okay and why well because we
can put them in one to one
correspondence namely for every integer
multiply it by two and then you get an
even number so the rules are a little
bit trickier a subset of the integers
may or may not be infinite in size but
if it is infinite in size it is equal in
cardinality to the integers as a whole
whereas the real numbers are a strictly
larger set there's a lot that is either
unknown or
Choice dependent about the trans-finite
numbers as they are known so there's the
Continuum hypothesis for example that
hypothesizes that there are no infinite
numbers with sizes between the real
numbers and the integers so there's the
set of the integers L if not and then
under the Continuum hypothesis lf1 would
be the number of real numbers that's
strictly larger but there's no infinite
numbers in between but that's not
something you can prove in the ordinary
language of set theory you can assume it
you can assume the Continuum hypothesis
as an axiom and that's completely
consistent but it's also consistent not
to assume it so that's where I stop
paying attention really like not because
it's not interesting but because it's
super weird and difficult and things
that we're not used to thinking about in
ordinary arithmetic so you kind of have
to specialize in it and bite the bullet
to really keep everything straight in
your mind and I have not put that work
into it as far as physics is concerned
I think that the natural answer is there
is no well what what should I say
um the the tempting answer let's put it
that way the tempting answer is it
doesn't matter if there are different
size infinite numbers because we human
beings can only sort of
experience finite things right even if
there's a Continuum of points in space
for example we can't measure exactly the
location of points in space we measure
things within a certain precision and
therefore there's in effect only a
finite number of outcomes we can get by
measuring things having said that you
know there might be examples of for
example cosmological scenarios the
universe being either infinite or finite
maybe there it does matter whether you
have different sizes of infinity or not
but I think all of that is very much in
the realm of speculation it's certainly
not something where your typical working
physicist needs to worry about the sizes
of different infinities
James tronson says given that the
universe is expanding what is it
expanding into rather if nothing exists
outside the universe how does it expand
so this is a classic question this is a
an old saw but that's okay we can dip
into those occasionally the answer is
it's not expanding into anything
and the answer is it doesn't need to
have anything outside the universe in
order to expand and the reasons why are
because when we're talking about the
universe some of your intuitions about
objects inside the universe are not
going to apply okay so we have
experience with balloons or raisin bread
or things like that objects within our
universe that expand and by expanding
they grow into the space that is around
them so so when cosmologists start
talking about the expanding Universe
they will very naturally use vocabulary
words that have grown up over the years
to uh to refer to things that we know
about in our everyday experience like
expand Etc
and your intuition then wants to attach
the features of things you know about to
the universe but they might not apply
okay so when we say the universe is
expanding what do we mean we mean that
the physical distance between distant
galaxies is larger now than it used to
be and smaller than it will be in the
future there is literally more physical
distance in between galaxies that
doesn't mean that there has to be
anything outside the universe the
universe doesn't have to expand into
anything this is a feature of
non-euclidean geometry and general
relativity that if you have even if the
universe is finite in size okay the
universe is like a three-dimensional
sphere in in space
then that sphere can have different
sizes and that sphere can grow or Shrink
over time
even if the universe is infinite you
know we were just talking about there's
an infinite number of numbers and and if
you double them it's still an infinite
number of numbers likewise if the
universe is infinite in extent you can
move everything apart from everything
else it's still infinite an extent but
in a very real sense it has expanded
okay so the mental switch you have to do
when you start thinking about general
relativity is that the geometry you're
talking about is intrinsic to the space
or space time that you're talking about
this was actually an idea that you know
came about from Gauss and Riemann and
those folks back in the 1800s you don't
have to imagine
embedding a geometrical figure into a
larger space you can just talk about its
properties intrinsic to the space itself
and that's what we do when we talk about
the universe
Craig Vandervest says well chat gpt's
deep language learning has been the rage
in 2023 a few years ago it was deep
reinforcement learning DRL provided
exciting Atari go and chess
demonstrations of superhuman game skill
I've heard that deep learning techniques
have been used on particle physics data
sets but are there other areas of
physics or philosophy that are or may be
productively explored for instance could
or are ontologies being explored using
DRL Brute Force techniques to help find
or outline paradoxes and conceptual
limitations that a human May yet be
blind to
I think that this is a very interesting
field that is is being thought about
right now the use of AI models in
physics I don't know about philosophy
that one I would not actually come
across but but maybe it could be look
there's certainly very down-to-earth
uses of deep learning machine learning
reinforcement learning in physics and
astronomy because we have giant data
sets to analyze right so it is a very
active field to use these techniques
deep neural networks things like that to
sift through large piles of data looking
for new particles or trying to
understand the distribution of galaxies
things like that okay that's not going
away that is a very exciting area but
you're not looking for new kinds of
things you're telling the computer what
to look for and it will find it or not
um
it's much harder to imagine using the
current kinds of AI programs to do truly
creative work in physics or philosophy
and that's I want to very quickly say
that's not because it's impossible it's
just because it's that's not what the
current set of models are trained to do
the current set of models are not even
very good at logical or mathematically
rigorous thinking right because they're
really very good at a specific thing
that specific thing is completing
sentences or drawing images or playing a
game
and that's not enough to come up with a
truly new you know picture of space-time
or something like that you know you
could imagine you know imagine going
back to 1910
and you could ask a uh but go back to
1910 but but bring along with you a
modern computer with AI programs
installed on it you could certainly you
know feed into it all the physics that
was known at the time and say you know
solve the following equations or look
for the following pattern or so forth
it's very hard to imagine the current
kind of AI programs that we have saying
oh you should think of space-time as
curved or oh you should replace
positions and velocities of particles
with a complex valued Quantum wave
function you know that's just not the
kind of thing that it is trained to do
you shouldn't hold that against the AI
programs just like you shouldn't hold it
against the uh the go playing programs
they're not good at horseback riding I
mean they're really very good at playing
go right
how should you design an AI program to
come up with truly novel ideas in
physics or philosophy or anywhere well I
don't know that's a good one that's a
good question I'm not saying it can't
happen I'm just saying that's not what
we've tried to do yet
Johann Falk says do you think large
language models and AI chat Bots will
affect the way we look at knowledge
good I think that this is a very good
question because the answer is maybe yes
you know
does an AI does a large language model
know things
in the in the sort of most strict
philosophical sense I'm not sure what
you should say about that clearly you
can ask it questions and it can tell you
answers sometimes those answers will be
wrong absolutely but very often if you
ask it a well-posed question the answers
will be right if you ask questions of
human beings they will sometimes be
wrong too right we don't hold that
against them the fact that they are
sometimes wrong if they have some very
large swath of knowledge that a human
being can reliably tell you the correct
answer to we would say it knows
something it has some knowledge why
shouldn't we attribute the same uh
statements to AI models and
but but but I should say not and but the
kind of knowledge is different right as
we discussed earlier
um and this goes back to podcast
conversations we've had with people like
Melanie Mitchell Gary Marcus Etc
um the way that large language models
have that knowledge is a different way
than human beings have that knowledge
human beings take the world and compress
it into models uh models that we might
call Common Sense or folk physics or
whatever but models of pieces of things
that have relationships between them and
interrelate to each other in various
ways whereas large language models are
really looking at llm that is right
there on the 10 they're looking at
language they are looking at What
sentences people have said in the past
and trying to figure out how words will
fit together in a certain way it's a
very different way of coming up with the
true statements that they come up with
it's not they don't come up with true
statements but they generate them in a
very different way than human beings do
so that's why I think it's a very
interesting question to ask does that
count as knowledge and I suspect that
what's going to happen is that we will
begin to distinguish between different
kinds of knowledge we will attribute a
kind of knowledge to a large language
model which is a different kind of
knowledge that a smart human being has
which isn't to say once again that you
couldn't invent a different kind of AI
program that also had the same kind of
knowledge that a human being has it's
just not what we have in an llm
Adam rotmill has a priority question
remember that priority questions are
things that you get once in your life
for every patreon supporter you get to
ask a question I will do my best to
answer it Adam has split his questions
to two parts which are really two
different questions and you are not
allowed to do that so I'm going to
answer the first one it's still only one
question per question that's still a
rule even for priority questions the
question is when I think about the first
second after the big bang my
understanding is that as we look
backward toward T equals zero the
temperature becomes hotter and hotter
until we approach infinite temperature
but when I think about what temperature
is I know it has to do with motion I
know there are many interactions in that
first second Carlo rivelli tells us the
time is the order of events from that
perspective I wonder if we can say that
the temperature becomes time-like as it
reaches Infinity such that the first
second might as well have been an
eternity
well no no in in all sorts of ways but
I'm not exactly sure what you mean at
some point in the question so when you
say I wonder if we can say the
temperature becomes time like I'm not
sure whether you mean temperature is
like time in the sort of casual sense or
time like is in the technical relativity
sense the difference between a
space-like trajectory one that goes
faster than the speed of light and a
time-like trajectory one that goes
slower I presume you mean the former
rather than the latter uh it's kind of
like time but
um maybe I'm getting this wrong I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do my best I'm not
quite sure what it means to say the
temperature becomes like time of course
in an expanding Universe the temperature
evolves essentially this there's
footnotes here and caveats as always but
essentially the temperature evolves
monotonically with time right
the 10 temperature of the universe only
ever goes down as the universe expands
sometimes it goes down faster sometimes
it goes down slower
Etc or thought the other way around
given the temperature of let's say the
microwave background now about 2.7
Kelvin if we contract the universe for
example by going to the past it becomes
hotter monotonically it never starts
cooling down
now it's true that sometimes you would
you hear people say that as you approach
the big bang you approach infinite
temperature that's a little bit sloppy
for a couple reasons number one there is
no big bang remember that the Big Bang
Singularity is just a prediction of
general relativity that we all expect to
be wrong so don't spend too much time
thinking about what life is like
literally at the Big Bang until you have
some quantum theory of gravity the Big
Bang model where the universe expands
and cools and galaxies form that's in
100 good shape but that's entirely
different than the Big Bang event at T
equals zero so you will hear people
sometimes nevertheless say you approach
infinite temperature but that's just an
extrapolation it's an extrapolation
beyond what we're allowed to talk about
right if you have a box of gas and you
squeeze it to smaller and smaller sizes
the temperature goes up and as you hit
zero size the temperature would go to
Infinity but you don't really never hit
zero size that's not a thing that
happens so
the the third thing to say about this is
of course the world is not a box of gas
it's not made of particles in that way
it's a It's Made maybe of quantum Fields
but maybe in quantum gravity it's made
of something even more subtle something
more purely quantum mechanical
in Quantum field Theory there are
definitions of the word temperature
other than uh it has to do with motion
right when Adam when you say I think the
temperature has to do with motion that's
not necessarily true in a Quantum field
Theory there are other definitions of
what you're talking about because you
don't have particles moving you have
Fields interacting and vibrating and so
forth so
I think that the you know in the spirit
of the question
um there's nothing really bizarre going
on as you approach T equals zero at T
equals zero this is going to be
something bizarre going on that we don't
know what it is but the approach is
pretty ordinary and normal there could
be things like phase transitions you
could have inflation and stuff like that
but the laws of physics don't need to be
changed in order to make that happen
having said all of that there are way
more speculative ideas not about
conventional standard Big Bang cosmology
but about quantum gravity and the
emergence of time uh in fact Carlo
ravelli is the co-author on one such
idea called the thermal time hypothesis
where indeed it's not that temperature
is playing the role of time but the
temperature
characteristics of a certain Quantum
system allow us to show how time emerges
in the thermal time hypothesis that's a
complex and subtle story I'm not sure
that I believe it entirely but it is out
there maybe that's what you're referring
to I'm not sure if it is then I don't
have that much to say about it I'm not
um I'm interested in it but I don't know
enough details to say much more
Brad malt says in your recent podcast
with Thomas hertog you explore applying
the rules of quantum mechanics to the
creation of the universe that got me
wondering presumably right after the big
bang everything in the quantum Universe
was in a state of superposition but what
would cause the first branching of the
wave function of the universe there was
no Observer to make the first
measurement or No macroscopic Object for
something to interact with and cause
decoherence
well this is actually a subtle question
I mean parts of it are easy to answer
and parts of it are more complicated
remember that observing has nothing to
do with anything
and if you believe many worlds at all
which I presume is going on uh beneath
this question one of the achievements of
the many worlds formulation of quantum
mechanics is to erase words like
Observer or measurement or anything like
that from the laws of physics those
words are in there in the Copenhagen
interpretation but in many worlds it's
just physical systems interacting with
each other okay so what do you mean by
what happens in the in the real world
when you do a Quantum measurement it is
something like decoherence and branching
of the wave function in order for that
to happen you have an environment that
is to say the degrees of freedom that
you're not keeping track of in your
system Etc and then you have the system
that you're looking at and they become
entangled and that's decoherence you can
do all of that right there near the big
bang you can just call the environment
the specific locations of all the
photons or the specific Quantum state of
all the fields that you're not paying
attention to right you're paying
attention into some things like maybe
the large-scale distribution of density
of matter or something like that but
there's other things that you're not
paying attention to and those are the
environment
if this sounds a little fuzzy then
that's fine it is fuzzy it's not just
you who thinks that it is a little bit
fuzzy you know I wrote a paper a few
years ago with Jason Pollock and Kim
body about the coherence during
inflation and its effect on Eternal
inflation because sometimes when people
talk about eternal inflation they act as
if the collapse of the wave function is
a truly objective event that happens
stochastically which would not be true
in many worlds it's it's an apparent
event caused by D coherence and so we
asked the question this this sometimes
happens when you're a theoretical
physicist we ask the question if you do
it right how does that change the answer
from what answers people have been
quoting and you find that it doesn't
change it very much at all it changes it
a little bit but not in a way that
really matters very much so this can be
done it's just the coherence there's
just an environment and you can do it
but it's not quite as easy as it is in
the laboratory in the laboratory it's a
little bit more straightforward which
parts of the world to call the
environment and which parts to call the
system in the early universe that's not
so straightforward so that's why it's
work that's why I have to write papers
about it rather than just quickly
calculating it and getting it on getting
on with your life
Bill McIntosh has a question it's a long
question so I kind of ending it down to
the essence here which is isn't it isn't
it possible or even likely that the
universe is so vastly large that
curvature is difficult to detect similar
to how an ant would assume the Earth is
flat in other words we talk about the
geometry of space in the universe on
very large scales and we say the
universe looks flat to us and Bill is
asking you know isn't it possible it's
just a little bit curved and we don't
notice yes it's a hundred percent
possible
um and so you know cosmologists are not
dummies they know that they try to
measure it and what you do is you don't
say the universe is flat we're done you
say the universe is the data that we
have on the universe is compatible with
it being flat and we can put error bars
on that we can say that it is true to
plus or minus a certain percent I don't
know what the percentage error bars are
now it's something like one percent five
percent something like that but by the
way you know beyond the part of the
universe we can observe beyond our
observable Horizon not only is it
completely possible that the universe is
not flat it's also completely possible
it's not smooth right it's not
homogeneous and isotropic there is this
game that gets played in the
popularization of cosmology where people
talk about three different geometries
the universe could have that could be
flat or it could be positively curved or
it could be negatively curved well those
are only the three different geometries
you can have if you assume that the
curvature of the universe is the same
everywhere both at every point and in
every direction and that seems to be an
assumption that is borne out on large
scales in the universe that we observe
but there's zero reason to think that
that assumption needs to continue to be
true beyond the universe that we're
actually able to see so there's an
infinite number of possible geometries
the universe could have it's not just
those three could be wildly different
from place to place
James Allen says how are we supposed to
make sense of fractional charges in
quarks it makes sense to say there's a
symmetry the charges can exist in units
of plus one or minus one but what is
guaranteeing that fractional charges add
up to integer multiples of that of the
electron could you have a charge a
particle with charge 0.7 or e or Pi well
it we don't know is the short answer
here you know the fact that the quarks
have one-third charges or two-thirds
charges is pretty much irrelevant to
this question what matters is that
they're rational numbers so that there
is always a certain number of charges
that add up to integers right if we
discovered quarks before we discovered
electrons we would have assigned them
charge one and we would have signed
assigned electrons charge three or minus
three nothing wrong with that at all it
is completely conventional the overall
scale doesn't matter so the right thing
to say is that in nature in the charges
that we know about they are all
multiples of each other they are integer
multiples or divisors of each other and
that's a question you can ask is that
necessary or is it optional Etc and the
answer is actually a little bit
interesting because if you might know
that
electromagnetism can be thought of as
being based on a U1 gauge theory if you
don't know what any one of those words
mean just wait until Volume 2 of the
biggest ideas in the universe comes out
it will all be explained in great detail
but if that's all you know and it's
basically you know Maxwell could have
said that almost not in those vocabulary
words but he knew the basic physics
there
then in principle you could be allowed
to have charges of any sort at all a
gauge Theory like that like
electromagnetism is does not by itself
put any restrictions on what the charges
can be however it turns out that if you
extend the electromagnetism to broader
contexts then you will often find that
there is now a restriction on the
charges of particles for example Paul
Dirac showed very long time ago that if
you have magnetic monopoles in the
universe so he was asking you know we
have electric charges that have plus or
minus charges and they are monopoles as
far as Electric electrical charge goes
which is to say they are just a plus
sign or a minus sign and all the lines
of force go directly toward the particle
and end there whereas for magnets we
have a North Pole and a South Pole we
always have both poles and the lines of
magnetic force kind of wrap around
inside so Dirac said could we have
magnetic monopoles like a North Pole
without a South Pole and he came up with
a way to do it and he showed that as an
implication of that way if there's even
just one monopole in the universe
magnetic monopole then the restrictions
of quantum mechanics imply that all the
electrical charges have to be quantized
in other words have to be multiple
integer multiples of some basic unit we
have never seen a magnetic monopole so
that may or may not be relevant to
nature but there are certain theories
that predict them
likewise if the U1 which which is the
Symmetry that leads to electromagnetism
is embedded in another kind of gauge
group like it is in Grand unified
theories that try to unify the strong an
electric weak interactions then you can
get charge quantization also so there's
speculative ideas for why charge needs
to be multiples of some basic unit but
we don't know whether any of those
specular speculative ideas are true and
they might they may or may not be it may
just be a fact that all the charges are
multiples of a basic unit that maybe
that's just one of the things we need to
live with
Jesse rimler says estimates are that at
least 500 000 Iraqis died as a result of
the US's invasion of Iraq and the
resulting war between 2003 and 2011. the
pretext for this invasion is now seen
even in the U.S as unjustified during
this conflict do you think it would have
been morally correct for a third Nation
to supply weapons Intel and even troops
to the Iraqis in order to defend against
the US's forces
so there's kind of two levels at which I
want to answer this one is the surface
level then there's the deeper level at
the surface level it I don't think that
the phrase
um
Supply weapons and Intel to their Iraqis
is well defined like who exactly are you
supplying these weapons in Intel too you
know we have the obvious analogy right
now the US supplying uh weapons and
Intel to Ukraine in its in its uh war
against Russia but there I think that
there's very good moral reasons here
since you're asking about moral um
justifications here I think the moral
reasons uh are very good to help Ukraine
in staving off the Russian invasion they
were invaded and they didn't want to be
invaded in Iraq it was a much more
complicated thing I think it you know
you can say in some vague sense that
Iraq did not want to be invaded But the
government of Iraq at the time was a was
a bad place right it's not at all
obvious that you would have been morally
correct to give weapons and Intel to
Saddam Hussein to help fight off the
United States
um I mean having said that I was not in
favor of the invasion myself I thought
it was like you said day cooked up for
the wrong reasons and that's bad but in
the real world of geopolitics you're not
just abstractly giving weapons and Intel
to countries you're giving them to
people or governments or whatever and in
the initial stages of the Iraq war that
would have been at least a little
slightly more morally questionable thing
to do now that you would have a better
case if you said well okay after Hussein
had fallen and we were later into
the war in Iraq there was still an
Insurgency going on right where Iraqis
were fighting against the United States
occupiers and there I think he would
have had a better case for giving them
weapons or Intel or whatever but it's
still a tricky case because when you
look closely at who was leading those
insurgencies they were also not the
nicest people in the world so again
maybe there was a case I don't I don't
remember the details well enough to go
into names and places and things like
that but I think you have to think it
through
um so that's the surface level of the
question
at the there's a sort of subtext level
of the question inspired by the
comparison between this situation and
the Ukraine situation which is a lot of
people
criticize the US and NATO giving support
to Ukraine on the basis that you
wouldn't want it done to you you
wouldn't want other countries to give
support to the places that you were
invading would you
know I think that's a very dumb bad
argument or even sometimes the argument
is put in as the United States has no
right to do this kind of thing or uh you
have no right to pass judgment on Russia
or Ukraine or whatever because the
United States has done so many bad
things in its past
I think that's just a silly thing to say
I mean the United States has absolutely
done all sorts of bad things in its past
and the right thing to do with respect
to that is to criticize it for doing
that it's not as if Americans think that
it's bad to criticize America Americans
criticize America all the time and you
know some more than others of course and
you should be thoughtful about how you
do that and think about it but there's
no moral guideline that says that you
just can't criticize other countries
until your country is completely correct
I think you should criticize all the
countries that are doing bad things your
own country as well as other countries
Sugar Pine press says do you suppose
that in the same way that the
contradictions that exist among a
multiplicity of religious beliefs lends
Credence to the theory that none of them
are correct or even that God doesn't
exist the contradictions between
numerous meta-ethical theories increases
the likelihood that none of them are
correct
not really no I don't I don't think so I
mean forget about difficult things like
Religion and Ethics and so forth there's
plenty of cases where we have multiple
theories because we don't know what the
Right theory is and yet one of them is
going to be correct right the fact that
there are multiple theories disagree
with each other I don't think is very
strong evidence that any one of them is
incorrect In the case of religions
that's it's a lot deeper than that you
know the story is a lot more complex
than that it's not just that there are a
lot of religious beliefs but that the
specific kinds of religious beliefs that
there are and the ways that they develop
you know in different countries and
things like that are to me exactly what
you would expect if none of them were
true right if it were really just human
beings telling each other stories rather
than saying something true and important
about the nature of the universe so that
may or may not be true in these other
cases where you want to compare them in
the cases of meta-ethical theories for
example I could very easily imagine that
one of them is true and the other is
just are not true like I don't I don't
see what the slightest uh impact that
there is on the existence of other
theories should should be for the theory
that I think is true maybe there is a
more detailed analogy analogy to be
spelled out there that I don't know
about but uh as it is I don't think that
has a lot of weight
Simon Carter says I know that Bell's
theorem does not apply to many worlds
because it just proves that a hidden
variable's interpretation can only be
non-local does many worlds assume
non-locality at the fundamental level
well it goes back a little bit to what
we've already talked about that the way
that you choose to describe the
branching of the universe is up to you
in some sense uh there are wrong ways to
do it for sure but there's not
necessarily a single right way to do it
and I think that someone like David
Wallace would say he has a way of doing
it that uh recovers locality at the
fundamental level I don't my way of
doing it does not have locality at the
fundamental level but I also don't think
you should have locality at the
fundamental level because I don't think
that physics has locality at the
fundamental level there is such a thing
as gravity and in a world with quantum
gravity you don't expect physics to be
purely local so as I've said before from
my perspective the thing to puzzle over
is not oh my goodness how are we going
to include non-locality in physics
rather it is oh my goodness why does the
world look pretty local to us in our
classical world I think you can try to
answer that question but I think that's
the one you should be focusing on the
surprise is not non-locality the
surprise is locality
Peter Musgraves says as a lapsed
relativist who went into software long
ago I've continued to monitor the new
physics textbooks on gr collecting some
along the way this week I get yet
another email from a publisher with yet
another new gr book on offer it seems
like there are several new textbooks on
gr per year this seems like a lot why do
you think people are writing gr books at
this rate what made you write your gr
textbook
I'm not sure if there are several new
textbooks on gr per year that would
sound like a lot uh by the way gr
general relativity for those of you who
are not in that subfield but I'm very
happy that there are multiple books out
there because the books are different
they're not just Xerox copies of each
other different people have different
ways of coming to terms with these
different ideas and so just among famous
books if you compare you know Bob wald's
book to Mizner Thorn and Wheeler to my
book to Jim hartle's book to Stephen
weinberg's book these are all radically
different books like none of these two
books look alike okay they're all
teaching you general relativity but all
in very different ways as far as what
made me write my gr textbook you know
when I was writing it I did have at
least one famous General relativist say
why are you writing another book we
already have wald's book we don't need
any more books but if you've ever looked
at Wall's book it is a is a brilliant
wonderful gorgeous book a true tour de
force and a you know a a
work of art in a very real way it's also
not the best way to learn general
relativity for the first time for many
people including myself and I say that
as someone who took a course that used
that book to teach so it's everything in
is in there and it's all correct but it
can be hard to extract sometimes so my
own book it's this is not exactly
correct but my book can be thought of as
you know walled translated into English
for people who are not thinking in the
pristine mathematical way that Bob Wall
thinks and it's not just that I I put
other things in there as well but
different books are gonna be useful for
different people I think that's the
least surprising thing in the world
really
Anthony nalt n-a-u-l-t says what grounds
space-time structure I like being human
about the laws of nature and wonder if
this intuition should extend to the laws
of geometry in other words why is
distant simultaneity a thing in
Newtonian space time but not even Kowski
in space-time are we just at ontological
bedrock
so I'm not at all sure that I understand
this question I like it I like the words
that appear in the question I'm not sure
that I'm getting what is being asked in
the sense of what grounds space-time
structure I mean when you say why is
distance simultaneous thing a Newtonian
space-time anonyminkowski space-time
part of me wants to say well
because it is like that's that's part of
how we constructed it I mean what
Newtonian space time is is literally an
absolute space with absolute time I mean
distant simultaneous just there built
into what you mean by Newtonian space
time whereas in minkowski space time
it's just not if what you're asking
rather is why is the world more like
minkowski's face time than Newtonian
space time that's a different question
and that I don't know what the answer is
um there is one nice feature that
relativistic space-time has that
Newtonian space-time doesn't which is
the speed of light limit you know those
of us who imagine hopping on a spaceship
and playing across the Galaxy might
think that the speed of light is
annoying it's very very slow but in
terms of physics it has this extremely
nice feature that it limits what you can
do in the universe if you clap your
hands right here right now in the room
you're in the impulse the impact of that
on the Universe cannot travel outward
faster than the speed of light in fact
it will travel out slower than the speed
of light as far as the sound is
concerned but the visible impact will
travel out at the speed of light but
that means that you cannot instantly
affect something a billion light years
away and then instantly be affected back
by it and that's kind of a convenient
thing when it comes to physics it sort
of provides a little bit of a limitation
on what you can do and as as you know in
physics very often we write down a
theory that looks pretty good but it has
some weird implications and I think that
Newtonian space time would have weird
implications because of this infinite
velocity that we would in principle be
able to have that we don't need to worry
about in the real world because we live
in something more like minkowski space I
mean it's not exactly minkowski's space
because the universe is curved the space
time but it's locally minkowskian
James Heath says is the Sleeping Beauty
problem the same as self-locating
uncertainty in many worlds and my
Credence about the coin flip should be
50 50.
the Sleeping Beauty problem for those of
you who don't know is a thought
experiment invented by philosophers I
think that Adam Elga
popularized it but I don't think that he
invented it so the prop the the puzzle
is this so Sleeping Beauty volunteers to
appear in a philosophy experiment okay
and the philosophy experiment is the
following thing you're going to give
Sleeping Beauty uh Sleeping Beauty is
going to go to sleep that's what she
does that's what she's good at and when
she's asleep you're gonna flip a coin if
the coin comes up heads she will wake up
the next morning call it Monday okay if
the coin and that's it that's all that
happens if the coin comes up Tails then
she will wake up the next morning Monday
and then she will be put to sleep again
with a memory erasing drug so that she
does not remember having woken up Monday
and then she will wake up again on
Tuesday okay so coin heads you wake up
once on Monday coin tails you wake up
twice once on Monday once on Tuesday in
both cases of course after that later on
she wakes up and she's fine she all she
knows ahead of time what the
experimental protocol is going to be
okay and the question that she's asked
when she wakes up is what is your
estimate what is your value that you
place on the probability that the coin
came up heads
and there are two very plausible
sounding answers one is well there's
three possible things I could be I could
be waking up Monday in the coin is heads
universe I could be waking up Monday and
the coin is Tails universe or I could be
waking up Tuesday in the tail and the
coin is Tails Universe those are three
possibilities I have no way of telling
there's no difference to any of them
when I wake up and therefore I would
give a one-third one-third one-third
probability so I'm a third or for the
coin coming up heads
the other argument says before I went to
sleep I would have said it's a 50 50
chance that the coin was heads or tails
after I go to sleep and wake up I'm a
good Bayesian I collect more data but
the data tells me nothing about whether
the coin was heads or tails therefore
base's theorem says it's still 50 50.
there's a 50 chance a halfer position on
the coin being heads to begin with so
yes this problem is very similar to many
worlds but it's not exactly the same
because the worlds are different in in
many worlds there are multiple worlds
but they're simultaneous with each other
they exist at the same time in Sleeping
Beauty problem in any one realization of
the experiment there's only a single
world so maybe you're comparing
different possible worlds or something
like that
I think that it is plausible but far
from obvious that we should treat
different possible worlds that you can
imagine in the same way as you treat
different actual worlds in the wave
function of many worlds so I'm I'm I
will be very honest my views on the
Original Sleeping Beauty problem go back
and forth uh as of the current moment I
am a heifer I think that the the
Bayesian argument that I gave you makes
more sense and partly this is because I
taught a chorus last fall on Topics in
philosophy of physics and we talked
about the Sleeping Beauty problem and
one of my students wrote a really good
paper that convinced me I should be a
hacker so but of course maybe next year
another student writes another paper
that points me the other way I've not
actually sat down I really do hope to
sit down and think about it and be able
to come up with an answer all of my own
so they're related is the short answer
but they're not exactly the same problem
Danny says how is the bass playing going
and what songs are you attempting to
learn so I'm only including this just to
say sorry that I haven't updated anyone
on my bass playing or anything else that
I'm doing in my life because I've not
been doing it I've not had time it's
been quite a year let me tell you and I
think that as as fun as it would be to
share some um stories about bass playing
out there uh it's more important for me
to finish writing this book so I gotta
do that I have to prioritize that sorry
about that the bass playing is not going
well because it's not going at all right
now
Justin Proctor says while I understand
that wimps weekly interacting massive
particles and axions are considered the
two leading candidates for dark matter
what exactly are the differences between
the two they're very very different uh
it's sort of an interesting feature that
particles that are so different from
each other can both be very viable
candidates for cold Dark Matter so by
the way Dark Matter some one of the
things we know about dark matter is that
it's cold what that means is that it's
the particles themselves were moving
very very slow compared to the speed of
light when they sort of first formed in
the very early universe and that's
important the fact that they're moving
slowly compared to the speed of light
because if they're moving fast compared
to the speed of light that would have a
big effect on the formation of
large-scale structure in the universe
and we would know it so there were ideas
early on about hot dark matter and so
forth those have been ruled out by
experiment
for very different reasons wimps and
axions are both cold Dark Matter even
though they're very different kinds of
particles weekly interacting massive
particles are you know they're kind of
like the Z boson you know the Z boson is
uh one of the force carrying particles
of the weak interactions
um it interacts weekly it has zero
electric charge the only difference is
that the Z boson is not stable it decays
away very very quickly so it's not going
to be a good candidate for dark matter
but if you somehow had a model of
particle physics in which there was a
thing like the Z boson but it was
perfectly stable that would make a very
good Dark Matter candidate so it's very
heavy you know a hundred times the mass
of the proton or something like that so
that's that's a lot so Mass the proton
is almost a billion electron volts so
those would be 100 billion or even a
thousand billion electron volts for a
wimp whereas axions are very light
particles less than a single electron
volt less than a thousandth of an
electron volt in fact and what you might
expect is that they're so light it
doesn't take a lot of energy to make
them move so you might expect them to be
hot dark matter but the Axion has a very
unusual way that it is formed from
spontaneous symmetry breaking in the
early universe so I'm not going to go
through the whole thing right now but
the upshot is that even though the Axion
particles are extremely light they move
very very slowly when they are formed
essentially zero velocity so even though
the the mass range here is very
different what is that 10 to the 16
difference between the mass of a of a
typical Axion and the mass of a typical
wimp they both count as cold dark matter
they also interact very differently with
ordinary manner wimps interact by the
weak interactions that's that's the name
axions interact primarily
electromagnetically with known matter
and in terms of at least the ways that
we are trying to look for the axions
that's the interaction that we're
looking for but it's a very very tiny
interaction because when I say interact
electromagnetically the axions are not
electrically charged they're neutral so
there's zero charge you might think they
don't interact with electromagnetism at
all but because of quantum field Theory
there's always indirect interactions the
Axion interacts with something that
interacts with photons so ultimately you
see an effective interaction with an
Axion and two photons or something like
that so there we've been very good at
building experiments looking for wimps
we've been less good at building
experiments looking for Axion that's a
little bit harder to look for and find
axions but we're trying so who knows
maybe we'll do it you know wimps could
have been found by now the searches are
that good it's not that we should have
found them by now but we had a chance
and we haven't yet so as a good Bayesian
your Credence that the darkness heteroz
axions should have gone up over the last
10 years or so
Jason says in some of your podcasts you
refer to the ongoing Decades of learning
where we shifted our view of energy
density in a space vacuum from being
zero to being significantly greater than
zero and ultimately validating the
cosmological constant my confusion from
an outsider perspective is was there a
legitimate belief at one point that the
energy density was exactly zero
well I think so I had that belief so I
think it was legitimate but to be
completely fair this is a tough game
where the rules are very unclear okay so
the what we're talking about here is the
cosmological constant the energy density
in empty space itself which by the way
is not significantly greater than zero
even if even if it is the thing that is
causing the universe to accelerate it's
still a very tiny number what 10 minus
eighth ergs per cubic centimeter or
something like that is the energy
density in the vacuum
and we didn't know we never had a theory
ahead of time for how big the
cosmological constant should be we had a
sort of hand wavy way of thinking about
it which said the following if you start
with some classical value of the
cosmological constant and then you turn
on quantum mechanics so you live in a
world where there are quantum fields and
the quantum Fields vibrate in their
vacuum State Etc
it turns out there are quantum
corrections to that classical value and
they tend to make the classical value
bigger and bigger and bigger in fact
naively they make it infinitely big so
that's a problem the cosmological
constant has Divergent Quantum
Corrections in our ordinary standing
understanding of quantum field theory of
course that's a little bit of a cheat
because to get those divergences you
have to include contributions that
arbitrarily small distances arbitrarily
large energies and those probably aren't
there so if you put a cut off on those
contributions at the Planck scale that's
where you get the idea that the
prediction is 10 to the 120 times bigger
than the actual value and so the logic
was the following
people knew that their naive prediction
and everyone agreed that it was naive
but it was the only thing we had the
naive prediction was that the vacuum
energy should be 10 to the 10 to the 120
times bigger than the limit we had on
how big it actually could be and they
said look we don't know why it's clearly
much smaller than that we would have
noticed if it were that big we don't
know why it's smaller but it's smaller
by at least a factor of 10 to the minus
120 from what we expect it to be and
here's here's where the magic happens in
the space of all possible theories that
we haven't yet thought of
it is easier for us to imagine a theory
that takes a big number all the way down
to zero
then theories that take a big number
down to 10 to the minus 120 that big
number because 0 has a symmetry right
zero is a nice round number and even if
we don't know why it's it's plausible to
imagine theories that would make the
vacuum energy exactly zero and in fact
there were plenty of candidates Sydney
Coleman came up with a famous
uh quantum gravity argument that the
cosmotional constant should be precisely
zero and there is no good reason there
was no theory on the market that said it
should be precisely 10 to the minus 120
times the Planck scale except for the
anthropic principle except for the idea
that if the vacuum energy took on
different values in different parts of
the Multiverse we would only be here if
it were small enough to allow us to
exist and Stephen Weinberg and others
pointed out that that would naturally
give rise to a vacuum energy of order 10
to the minus 120 what the what the
playing scale prediction really was so
I think that that argument was fine I
think that was a good argument that the
cosmological constant is probably zero
it certainly was never an airtight
argument it's not you know a statement
along the lines of here is the correct
Theory of Everything the correct set of
laws of physics that I'm going to use to
predict the cosmological constant and
get you a definite answer that was never
it
it was always and and supposed to be a
way of reasoning about what would seem
natural to us given that we don't know
the final answer it turned out to be
wrong okay I think it was wrong it's
still possible the cosmological constant
is zero and the actual dark energy is
something else but I think the smart
money is the cosmological constant is
not zero so that reasoning was wrong so
that's good that's a clue that's helping
us move in the direction of something
that is more correct but we're not there
yet we don't have the final answer to
those kinds of questions
James Swift says you've mentioned
writing a little bespoke software
yourself in the past to help with some
research problems and I've heard other
academics talk about it as a necessity
on occasion
but I also get the impression that it's
frustrating and too time consuming
especially since they are not often
trained or very experienced in software
development my question is given the
modern culture of Open Source
development do you think it would be
useful for academics to put out calls
for software to The Wider Community
perhaps they do this already and I am
unaware
yeah they absolutely do do this uh now I
think that there's don't get the wrong
impression there's plenty of academics
plenty of physics professors who write
software all the time at a very deep
sophisticated level I just happen not to
be one of them I'm more of a pencil and
paper person myself and for better for
worse the following thing happens the
people who know enough about open source
development and how to use GitHub and
things like that are also the people who
are perfectly competent at just doing it
themselves so you know they will always
be happy to Outsource certain
subroutines or whatever certain tasks
that are relatively common and they can
plug into their software but for the
most part really hardcore computational
physicists are going to have to write it
themselves or at least their team of
grad students and postdocs and so forth
will write it along with them so it's a
give and take what what the open source
Community would be useful for is people
who almost never write software here but
those people also don't know how to take
advantage of the open source Community
to find what they need so and maybe they
don't need to like if they don't use the
software that much it's just easier to
write the little bit themselves when
they when it when the need arises
tarun asks is as a human constructivist
does the criticism that this point of
view leads to a form of moral relativism
concern you
no it does not concern me I mean there
are actually moral relativists it
doesn't concern them either
um I think that it doesn't who cares
whether it concerns you or not is is one
way of of stating my response to this if
it's true you have to deal with it I
mean my the thing that I um am most but
but the highest highest Credence on is
that there are no objective moral truths
out there in the world that I'm very
pretty confident in
um again not 100 never 100 always
willing to change my mind but pretty
confident in less confident in what we
should do about it I do think that there
are ways of moral reasoning as a
constructivist
um and I can talk about you know why we
use it in one way rather than another
Etc but I think that's the best we can
do there's just no choice I don't take
seriously the option of pretending that
there are real morals strictures out
there in the universe that I should
listen to Just because I worry that
someone else is not going to agree with
my Arguments for take taking a certain
moral stance or another one
constructivists remember
just take seriously the idea that we're
human beings who are constructing our
moral systems and that's okay that's all
we have so there's nothing that we
should regret or feel bad about or be
concerned about just because of that
it's just accepting the real world for
what it is
Laurent delamere says is it possible to
know how different our universe would be
if physics were simpler I.E none of the
complexity of the quantum mechanics of
quantum mechanics exists only the
classical physics and standard model of
particles well I think that you put the
word simpler in quotes which is a good
thing to do but maybe you should be even
more impressed with how ill-defined that
is in a context like this I don't think
it's at all obvious maybe in fact it's
obviously false to say that quantum
mechanics is more complex than classical
mechanics it is less intuitive to us
and quantum mechanical structures lead
to complex systems but I'm not quite
sure what the objective measurements of
complexity or Simplicity would be
According to which quantum mechanics is
more complex than classical mechanics
furthermore and a more down to earth
level you cannot say only classical
physics in the standard model of
particle physics because the standard
model really really really needs quantum
mechanics to make sense you need quantum
mechanics to make sense of atoms right
without quantum mechanics electrons
would spiral into Atomic nuclei and
matter would be dramatically unstable so
there's no such thing as a a model of
the world that is essentially classical
but looks more or less like our world
the macroscopic world that we live in
looks essentially classical but we know
that when we put a microscope on it it
begins to look Quantum and we don't know
how to not do that we don't know how to
get a purely classical World unless
you really just didn't have atoms and
molecules you just had fundamental
substances right steel and wood and
water and air we're all just separate
fundamental substances with their
different properties that would be a
possible world where you could be
classical that and I say that because
that was the world that people thought
they lived in 200 years ago right
um but it's not a simpler world it's a
world where you have a lot of
fundamental
materials and substances that's way more
complex than the quantum world we think
we live in
Andrew Goldstein says it seems like the
ultimate conundrum when we humans try to
study our own psyche how can we arrive
at objective conclusions when we are
both the subject and the Observer I've
heard Richard Feynman was skeptical
about the science of psychology and
psychoanalysis
you know I think that um it's okay to be
skeptical about psychology and
psychoanalysis but I mean in a very
short question I feel like there's a lot
to say here one there's a huge
difference between psychology which is
the study of human beings and how they
think and things like that versus
psychoanalysis which is one school of
therapy founded by Sigmund Freud within
the psychological tradition so those are
very different things
two you can be skeptical about the
amount of progress that has been made in
Psychology because human beings are hard
they're complicated it's difficult to
study them and we have you know a desire
within Academia to get surprising
results and things like that this leads
to replication crises and so forth so
that doesn't mean we shouldn't do it or
that it's impossible it just means that
it it's hard and we should take that
difficulty seriously third
um who cares whether Richard Feynman was
skeptical about it I mean either there
are reasons to be skeptical or not I
don't think that Feynman uh is a special
expert on the reliability of psychology
so I wouldn't put a lot of weight on on
that thing
the final thing is you're pointing to a
specific reason why you might be
skeptical about the ability of
psychology to make progress namely that
we are the subjects that we are studying
right we are both subject and the
Observer and I think that that's
absolutely something to take seriously
and keep in mind you know we have
intuitive feelings about how people act
how they think and so forth because we
are people who act and think and so
forth and so we never come into this
particular set of experiments without
any opinions about what is going on and
that can get in the way there's no
question about that but guess what we
can also just study other human beings
we can look at what other human beings
do we can make hypotheses we can test
them against data all that is is
possible so I don't think it's any
fundamental barrier sort of
epistemologically to making sense in
Psychology there's just a practical
difficulty that human beings are kind of
complicated
Astro Nobel says is there any particular
reason why we call neutrinos matter and
anti-neutrinos anti-matter or could they
have been named the other way around
just as well there actually is a reason
if you think about the decay of the
neutron okay beta Decay as it's called
because it gives off a Beta Ray and back
in the early days now we know it's just
an electron so a neutron is slightly
heavier than a proton and will Decay
after a few minutes if it's left alone
into a proton an electron so the charges
cancel out but also an anti-neutrino
those three particles you need all of
them and the experiments have have
verified that picture very well why an
anti-neutrino well if you think about
lepton number okay the number of leptons
in the universe the number of leptons in
the universe in every experiment that
we've ever done is conserved it's a
constant we have speculative ideas about
how maybe it's not a constant in nature
dealing with the matter antimatter
asymmetry and so forth but we've never
done an experiment where lepton number
was not conserved but that doesn't mean
the total number of leptons plus
anti-leptons it means the total number
of leptons
minus the total number of anti-leptons
is conserved so when you have a neutron
how many leptons do you have zero
because leptons are electrons and and
muons and neutrinos and so forth the
neutron is a baryon not a lepton so you
have zero leptons lying around
if you said that the neutron decayed
into a proton a neutron sorry a proton
an electron and a neutrino a real
neutrino not an anti-neutrino then you
would have that lepton zero initial
State going to a lepton number two final
State because you have an electron and a
neutrino so you violated lepton number
whereas if you say that I am saying it's
an anti-neutrino with lepton number
minus one that is created during Neutron
Decay then the number of leptons minus
the number of antileptons is zero both
before and after and you can um keep
that conservation law intact now there's
reasons why there's that conservation
law and there's interactions in electric
weak model Etc you can go through all
that furthermore you could just choose
to to use intentionally dumb notation
right to call what we call the
anti-neutrino the neutrino and then just
nevertheless assign it a different
lepton number but this way does make a
lot of sense there really is there
really are differences between neutrinos
and anti-neutrinos in how they interact
with other kinds of particles
Casey Mahone says the eternalist view of
time makes perfect sense to me on an
intellectual level but I find that it
betrays my intuitive sense of the world
in such a deep way that I struggle to
really believe it this is also true of
many things in physics such as the
branching of the wave function have you
gotten to the point where you can
effortlessly see these Concepts playing
out in the world around you and make
them feel real or is it simply enough
for them to fit together on an
intellectual and conceptual level
I think that they mostly feel real to me
you know I'm not going to say that I
have a complete intuitive grasp of
various high-level Concepts in physics
and certainly not in mathematics but I
think that what we call our intuition
changes it's we can train it over time
so the eternalist view of time for
example I have no trouble at all
thinking about it it just makes perfect
sense to me I I honestly do have trouble
not thinking of time in an eternalist
perspective I have even trouble
articulating what a non-italist is
trying to say so I think there's a
journey you come through you start with
some folk naive manifest image kind of
picture of the world you learn new
things you struggle to internalize them
and at the end of the day you think
about them very differently so that you
actually have trouble remembering what
it was that you originally thought about
things
Kyle Stevens says the Sixers have again
failed to make it out of the second
round of the playoffs I don't know why
all you uh patreon supporters are are
just riling me up about the Sixers like
this but I I get that we're all in it
together so that's okay anyway Kyle uh
continues on subsequently Doc Rivers has
been fired and the team seems to be due
for a shake-up the coaches for the bucks
and the Suns two other Playoff teams
with championship aspirations who fell
short this year have also been fired
coaches in today's age seem to have a
very short leash do you think that this
is the right approach to take in the
Quest for a championship well I think
this is a very hard question actually
I'm glad that I don't have Daryl mori's
job as uh president of basketball
operations for the Philadelphia 76ers
um
trying to judge the track record the
empirical success of a coach in team
sports is just a really hard thing to do
because guess what the players matter
more than the coach overall and also
crazy things matter like random luck and
you know various situations that you can
find yourself in and not really be in
control over so there are coaches who
have had good records and coaches who've
had bad records even though they are
good coaches and bad coaches
respectively nevertheless it's your job
as the general manager or the president
to try to find the best coach for your
team you know I think that there are
absolutely situations where a coach can
be kind of
objectively good and yet have run their
course for the team right you know at
some point the players start start
tuning out the coach almost no matter
how good they are or maybe they're just
not a good fit in the case of the Sixers
you know Daryl Mori who is the boss was
hired after Doc Rivers was hired as the
coach so Mori did not hire Doc Rivers
and he so he has now managed to hire his
own choice for the Cogen and Daryl was
always very very supportive of Doc
Rivers and I would say that Doc Rivers
gets a bad rap in Philly I think he was
a good coach but I don't think he was
great I think that you know the specific
shortcomings he had kind of showed up
year after year so I I'm I think it made
perfect sense uh to let him go as long
as the owners want to keep paying him
you know because he had a contract so
they have to keep paying him even though
he's no longer employed as far as the
other teams the Bucks and the Suns I
really don't know I was very surprised
in Milwaukee Bucks fired their coach
um I thought they had had a lot of
success but you know people get
impatient and likewise for the sons but
maybe those people have inside scoop
maybe the owners or the general manager
of those teams knows something about the
locker room or the practices or the
strategies that were used on the court
that I don't know about right so I
simultaneously think that
um the the implication of your question
is probably true that there are owners
and management structures that are too
impatient and are not unwilling enough
to let coaches
um work through some occasional rough
patches and I think that it makes sense
sometimes to fire your coach even if
you've been doing pretty well so again
that's why I'm glad I don't have that
job
Peter blankenheim says a few weeks ago
your guest Thomas hertog said the cosmic
inflation created a universe and a
fraction a big universe rather in a
fraction of a second I've read elsewhere
that at the end of the inflationary
Epoch what is now our observable
universe was about the size of a
watermelon if inflationary theory is
correct what is your best estimate for
the size of our universe at the end of
it I think the important thing here is
you really have to take seriously the
distinction between the size of the
universe and the size of what is now our
observable universe right because the
universe we have no idea how big it is
it could be infinitely big for all we
know it could be some finite size so the
relevant thing is to not care about the
size of the universe but we can care
about the relative size of the universe
at different moments in time uh the
important thing for inflation is it
expands by a factor of something like e
the number e to the power 60 or more it
could expand by much much more than that
but um we don't know that's I've written
papers about it there are different
people who have different thoughts about
it uh and so forth as far as our
observable universe on the other hand uh
yeah when it was at very very high
energy scales if you go backwards so
it's nothing to do with inflation you
just take the post-inflationary universe
and you can ask how big was it when it
was a certain temperature the observable
universe today and I think if I I think
I remember I don't know I haven't done
this lately but I think that our
observable universe if you push it all
the way back to the playing scale was
something like a centimeter across
um and of course if you have inflation
the thing about inflation is we don't
know that much about it including when
it ends and what the temperature was but
it might not be that much smaller than
the Planck energy therefore it might be
a little bit bigger than a centimeter so
watermelon size that's completely
reasonable but honestly we don't know
for sure because we don't know when
inflation ended even if inflation did
happen
Jeff B says I'm very fascinated by the
idea of of athentasia the inability to
visualize things in one's mind I believe
that my own ability to visualize is
probably quite weak but I'm able to do
it I tend to think more in words and
Impressions than in images there is a
test that is often given for
visualization ability you're asked to
visualize an object in your mind such as
an apple then you'll be asked questions
about the Apple you visualized such as
its color or size if you have a strong
ability to visualize then all these
details should be obvious to you without
you needing to fill them in all after
the fact do you know where your ability
to visualize may fall on the scale and
how important do you find it to do how
important do you find it when doing work
in physics yeah I did I took one of
these tests a while ago years ago and I
think that my ability to visualize is
pretty high although not super duper
High my artistic skills are nearly
non-existent so I can't visualize well
enough to then reproduce anything with
my hands but I do have if I think about
an apple an image of an apple that is
more than just a cartoon image or
something like that so it's pretty good
not super duper great how important is
it to doing physics
I think not much but I'm not sure
because of course in physics we often
deal with things that can't be
visualized at all and it's more
important to understand the equations
that generalize from simple cases you
know the two-dimensional plane or
whatever where you can visualize things
to 10 dimensional space-time or 10 to
the 10 to the 122 dimensional Hilbert
space where you simply can't you just
have to understand how to deal with the
equations on the other hand there's
absolutely cases in physics where
visualization is helpful I think that
intuition is very very helpful but I
think that different people have
different kinds of intuition some kinds
of intuition are going to be quite
visual some are going to be quite
symbolic you know I had a friend in grad
school who you know thought of tensors
as multilinear Maps which is the
technical definition of tensors but even
you know just starting out he had a much
easier time thinking of a formula with
little slots in it for various arguments
rather than a picture you know that was
his style of of thinking of things and
whatever works for you is what I'm in
favor of
Jim Murphy says a few months ago I asked
about whether you have any Star Struck
students or if other professors treat
you differently due to being a public
personality you essentially said that
you may view me as famous but it largely
goes unnoticed in my day-to-day life
which I think is true despite this if I
were to meet you I would definitely be a
little bit Starstruck and nervous to say
hello since you're the only famous
person I have a chance to communicate
with regularly I wanted to ask how does
it feel to have this star struck power
over other people and how would you
prefer a fan to approach you in public
if at all I don't think it's really any
power over people at all to be perfectly
honest not trying to be falsely modest
there um you know some people are fans I
get that that's great I I love it I
appreciate it
um and you know if someone sees me and
recognize me and wants to just politely
say hi and they like the podcast or the
books or whatever that's wonderful I'm
all in favor of it uh if I'm in the
middle of a conversation or having
dinner or whatever then don't stick
around for too long you know let me get
back on with my life but I don't think I
just think it's ordinary politeness
going on here I don't think there's
anything very special about so I
wouldn't I wouldn't sweat it too much
just be an ordinary considerate polite
person and you're fine
Tim Allman says I've been reading
Leonard huskins book The Cosmic
Landscape which contains much discussion
about the anthropic principle he defines
it as the principle that requires that
the laws of nature be consistent with
the existence of intelligent life the
statement seems to me to be devoid of
predictive or explanatory power simply
because the existence of a friendly
Universe does not imply that intelligent
life must develop I seem to be missing
something would you please comment on
the anthropic principle and why some
people take it seriously well I have to
confess I think that Lenny's book
Leonard husk and former mindscape guest
his book The Cosmic Landscape I I was
not a fan of that book honestly I think
that he kind of dashed it off it had
that feeling about it
whereas his follow-up book to that which
was the black hole Wars I think is one
of the best books ever written about
science about physics at a high level
for a broad audience
um so he just he just wasn't inspired
when he was writing the Cosmic Landscape
and I do think that these issues of the
anthropic principle are precisely places
where philosophy is useful important and
not every physicist takes it as
important and I think that therefore you
you get some sloppy statements about
what it says there's different versions
of the anthropic principle I think the
most straightforward one is that it's a
selection effect if you have a situation
where there are many different
environments in the universe then
intelligent life will only arise in
those regions where the conditions allow
for the existence of intelligent life
that sounds totalogical but it's the
conditional that is doing all the work
here if you have a universe with many
different kinds of conditions from place
to place you know by the way we do in
some sense here in the solar system
conditions are very different on the
surface of the Earth versus the interior
of the Sun versus interplanetary Space
right guess what life has arisen in
those regions here in the solar system
which are hospitable to the existence of
life now what does that get you why is
that a useful thing to say well it it
means that you shouldn't necessarily
generalize from just what you see to the
rest of the whole picture back in the
day before people knew that planets were
just like the Earth and the Sun was a
star and things like that
um you might very well have thought that
most of the universe was hospitable to
life right most of the universe was kind
of like the Earth that we live on now we
know better that was a mistake to have
thought that because of course you're
subject to the selection effect that you
are seeing the part of the universe that
allows you to exist
if the universe is just single if going
now to the cosmic universe so we have
the Multiverse with possibly different
regions with different laws of physics
and things like that
there's a comparison you want to do
between two different kinds of scenarios
one is that Multiverse scenario and one
is just a single Universe where things
like the cosmological constant and other
parameters of particle physics do allow
for the existence of life and the point
is it affects scientific practice in a
very clear-cut way if you knew there
were a Multiverse where the cosmological
constant took on different values from
place to place certainly you would not
spend your time trying to think of a
theory that predicted the value of the
cosmological constant uniquely once and
for all because it wouldn't be right
because you know the cosmological
constant is different in different
places but we don't know whether that's
our universe or not so there is still
some motivation for looking for theories
where you predict the cosmological
constant once and for all because maybe
there is only the cosmological constant
we observe and we're trying to explain
why but we keep in mind that maybe
that's not the explanation maybe the
explanation is just it takes on very
different values from place to play and
the anthropic principle tells us we live
in the part of the universe where it is
small and allows for life to develop
Dennis Briggs says I have your you are
here t-shirt it shows the low complexity
with both low and high entropy I cannot
explain to curious observers that what
may appear to be a contradiction you've
said before is because of gravity or
lack thereof could you expand yet again
on that
so I don't think it's because of gravity
actually uh the thing that is because of
gravity is the statement that in our
actual Universe the early Universe looks
both thermal right like a black body at
a constant temperature and a very smooth
and yet is low entropy that to explain
those facts to reconcile those facts you
need gravity but the T-shirt you're
talking about shows two graphs one where
entropy is just increasing with time and
the other is complexity is first
increasing and then decreasing and
that's going to be true whether or not
gravity is involved and by the way it's
not necessarily true there are
absolutely possible evolutions of the
universe where complexity never evolves
okay sometimes with the right conditions
the right laws of physics right Dynamics
complexity can evolve but it doesn't
have to so the general form of the curve
where it goes up and goes down is going
to be true but maybe it goes up almost
invisibly and or maybe it goes up by a
lot now why is complexity low on the far
left and the far right well think about
what it means to be very low entropy
think about a box of gas right low
entropy means that the gas is confined
to some really tiny region it's you know
not taking up all the phase space that
it could take up and that means there
just aren't a lot of States low entropy
means there aren't a lot of states that
you can be in so there's not a lot of
room for things to be complex there's
not a lot of specification of what's
going on whereas at high entropy then
everything is in equilibrium right
everything is as smooth as it could
possibly be when you're at high entropy
and that is also not very complex in
order for complexity to exist you need
enough room to wiggle around and enough
room for the things to arrange
themselves in interesting ways without
being completely smoothed out into high
entropy equilibrium so without knowing
as a matter of fact how complexity does
evolve at any particular system we can
say with pretty much confidence that in
ultra low entropy situations it will be
simple and in ultra high entropy
situations things will also be simple
Andrew Jaffe says I enjoyed the Andy
Clark episode it got me thinking if the
brain utilizes a predictive algorithm to
create our reality and presumably
improve our survival is not also
creating the sense of time passing
psychedelics appear to break the brain's
ability to utilize his past experience
to seamlessly produce a smooth changing
landscape while also altering one's
sense of time does time then not exist
outside of the mind so I was with you
right there until the end Andrew
the you have to distinguish between time
and our experience of time right I mean
those are very they're related but
they're obviously very different things
when you're asleep you're not
experiencing time that much at all if
you're not dreaming or whatever but time
is still passing after you're dead time
will still be passing but you will not
be experiencing it so time passes time
is Real Time exists outside of the mind
but under what circumstances and exactly
how do we appreciate it passing do we
experience it passing do we feel the
passage of time and I do think that it's
a subtle question I mean ultimately the
answer is because entropy is increasing
but that's always the beginning of the
answer that's not the end of the answer
entropy is increasing and the particular
way in which it is increasing leads to
certain phenomena whether it's you know
mixing of cream into coffee or having a
memory of the past or predicting the
future you know the way I like to think
about the passage of time is at any one
moment of time your brain carries with
it images of the immediate past and the
immediate future the immediate past
being its most recent memory what is
just saw or heard out there in the
universe and the immediate future it's
predicting what's going to happen next
and it is constantly updating both of
these as more experiences come in as you
live in the world and breathe Etc you're
constantly making new predictions for
what happens next constantly updating
your picture of what the universe was
just like and it's that constant sense
of updating that gives us the sense of
time flowing
Louis B says I've been really moved by
your series of arguments on the physics
of Consciousness that makes the point
that proponents of non-physical theories
of Consciousness really have to actually
choose between their non-physical
components either having no effect or
interacting in a way that violates in
profound ways the laws of physics in our
brain what I haven't heard is if you've
heard any responses to this are there
any popular replies any that you find
interesting
short answer is no I have not had any
responses that I find interesting
obviously this kind of argument that I
make it's not unique to me other people
have made it the the thing that is
slightly unusual or different about the
way that I make it is really emphasizing
the laws of physics side of things you
know I want to not talk too much about
the details of Consciousness I want to
put the burden of proof where it lies if
you think you need to violate the laws
of physics or change them or alter them
or whatever tell me exactly how and tell
me exactly how that's supposed to be
compatible with these enormous amount of
evidence that we have and people are
very some people are very eager to open
their minds to changing the laws of
physics without doing the work doing the
homework of being very precise about how
those changes should happen and I don't
even mean write down the theory of
everything that includes Consciousness I
mean at all tell me how you are
literally changing the laws of physics
rather than just saying oh I have a
thing a new picture of new kind of stuff
tell me how that new kind of stuff
interacts or even not new stuff but new
Properties or new origins or new Natures
tell me how it changes the ordinary
Behavior predicted by physics and people
don't do that
um so you know I'm gonna keep talking
about it uh Philip Goff and I are having
a little debate in September
um hopefully it will be recorded and put
online and and maybe that will spread
the word a little bit more you know it's
one thing to have ideas and to put them
out there is another thing to get people
to listen to them right I'm not a
Consciousness uh expert so uh I I'm not
the first person people turn to in that
in that regime but my paper on
Consciousness and the laws of physics
was published uh people have have read
it so hopefully it'll have some impact
Stephen Lord says from Andy my
seven-year-old who listens to your
podcast with wrapped attention hi Andy
how's it going
the quote is what if the Multiverse
contains groups of universes that share
the same laws of physics but whose
Evolution differs what possible
differences could there be between
universes within the same group yeah
that is absolutely 100 possible in fact
it's easier right
um maybe different regions of space-time
that we are attempted to label as
different universes have different local
laws of physics maybe they don't that's
not something that we really know for
sure but it's very easy to imagine
different regions of the universe with
the same laws of physics but slightly
different initial conditions especially
because we think you know the leading
candidate for the origin of the
fluctuations and the perturbations in
the early universe that led to galaxies
and stars and all the large-scale
structure in the universe eventually
evolving was a fundamentally Quantum
fluctuation driven process so when you
look at the pattern of galaxies is
spread across the sky has seen some
Galaxy survey or something like that the
idea is that that's a particular
observation of a Quantum fluctuating
initial condition and if you believe
many worlds version of quantum mechanics
that means that there are many many
other branches of the wave function
where the galaxies are in different
places so I think that the physics being
the same means that the evolution if
from roughly similar initial conditions
will be roughly the same you know the
number of galaxies the type of galaxies
the type of stars will all be
statistically the same but the specific
examples of which stars and galaxies
there are could of course be very
different not to mention things like the
evolution of life could be very very
different because that maybe depends on
some details we don't really know yet
Lewis mccartan asks a priority question
saying in special relativity there's no
objective notion of now there's no fact
of the matter about distant simultaneity
if this is true how do we think about
distant observers if my buddy is on
Alpha Centauri how do I think about
their conscious experience does the
relativity of simultaneity change
anything about this does it impact how
we should think of each other or do I
just regard them as conscious like
normal they move through their world
line through their perspective and I do
the same
yeah the latter it's completely normal
like living on Alpha Centauri you
wouldn't if there was a nice Earth-like
planet around Alpha Centauri you
wouldn't feel anything different just
because you're four light years away
from the earth right from their
perspective everything is completely
normal the only new thing in special
relativity where like you say there is
no objective notion of now is there is
no objective notion of now so there is a
set of experiences experienced by your
friend on the planet around Alpha
Centauri it's just that none of them
none of those moments in their lifespan
correspond to something you can identify
as what's going on now
so their life is completely normal but
you have to think of the
four-dimensional span of their life this
is why eternalism is one of the reasons
the big reason why eternalism the idea
that all moments in time are created
equal are equally real both past present
and future became much more popular
after relativity came along because you
can't even Define what you mean by this
present that is supposed to be special
and existent there's no such thing as
the present moment stretching throughout
the Universe individual people at every
moment call that moment now but they're
going to keep calling it now a year from
now they'll still say yes this is now so
you just have to get used to not
attributing nowness to people who are
very far away
Paul Hess says my son and his friend in
advanced 10th grade chemistry class
posed this question to their teacher who
was stumped can you help
in quantum physics when a photon with a
precise energy required to transition an
electron from the N equals one shell to
the N equals two shell interacts with a
neon atom where the N equals two shell
is already fully occupied what would be
the expected outcome considering the
principles of quantum mechanics
particularly the poly Exclusion
Principle would the electron in the N
equals one shell still be able to absorb
this Photon and attempt to transition to
the N equals two shell if not what
alternative interactions might occur so
just to sort of rephrase what the
question is going on here you have the
Pali Exclusion Principle which says it
is only one Quantum uh one particle one
fermionic particle like an electron
allowed per Quantum State and so you
have shells around atoms and maybe all
those shells are filled up with
electrons so there's no more electrons
you can put there and you could have a
situation where you could have had an
electron transition from one shell to
the other because it was hit by a photon
and it bounced upward but if the new
shell that it wants to go to is full
what happens the answer is it doesn't go
there it doesn't matter that a photon
passes by in quantum mechanics what
you're going to do is you're going to
calculate the probability
that that Photon interacts with the
electron in such a way as to send it to
some new state and if all the new states
that it might want to go to are full
then you calculate that probability and
it turns out to be zero and that's fine
you know there are such a thing as
photons passing by atoms not interacting
with them at all that's what would
happen in this case
qubit says let's assume that I have the
wave function of the universe and I want
to divide it up into different summons
Each of which corresponds to a different
world and cannot interact with any other
summons I think we would ordinarily say
components or branches but I get what
you're talking about I believe there are
many possible ways to do that how do I
know the correct way which actually
corresponds to the Real Worlds that I
could potentially experience is it also
possible to derive this correct wave
splitting from the Schrodinger equation
or do we have to add it from the outside
as an additional postulate
well you can't you're right that once
you have a vector I mean forget about
Hilbert's face and complicated things
think about a vector okay
um I can put a vector in a vector space
just a two-dimensional Vector I can have
X and Y coordinates and I can talk about
the X component of that vector and the Y
component of that Vector but I can also
rotate my coordinate system and have X
Prime and Y Prime coordinates and with
the original Vector I can now talk about
the X Prime component and the Y Prime
component and when I have many many many
many more Dimensions there's
correspondingly a lot more ways to do
that so the math itself just in the
Hilbert space description or the
Schrodinger equation does not tell you
how to divide the wave function up into
Worlds and this is called the preferred
basis problem in quantum mechanics but
we kind of know how to solve it and the
answer is something called pointer
States and D coherence so you know that
D coherence happens when some Quantum
system becomes entangled with its brow
water environment and the question is
why I mean think of it in terms of
Schrodinger's cat Okay Schrodinger's cat
is in a superposition of awake and
asleep you open the box you always see
it either awake or asleep and as far as
the quantum mechanical description of
the cat goes there is absolutely a
possible basis for the cat's wave
function which is one over the square
root of two catawake plus catasleep
that's one basis vector and the other
basis Vector is one over square root of
two catawake minus catasleep okay those
are two good basis vectors just as
awaken asleep individually are good
basis vectors but when we open the box
we never see the cat in a state of one
over square root of two awake plus
asleep or minus asleep we see either
awake or asleep all by itself why
because those are the pointer States
those are the states that are robust
under being monitored by the environment
think about it this way if the cat was
in a superposition of two different
macroscopic positions
immediately would become more entangled
with the environment because the photons
in the Box would hit the cat differently
depending on whether it was in one
position or another it's only when
you're in the pointer state which is
sort of a macroscopically coherent
Ensemble like a cat that is awake or a
cat that is asleep then the photons in
the Box interact with the cat they get
absorbed by it or they reflect off it or
what have you but they don't entangle
with it as we already talked about
earlier in the AMA because they don't
interact with it differently depending
on different parts of its wave function
so there is a whole discourse uh voichek
zurac is the is the guy who is his name
is generally associated with this
understanding why we see certain pointer
states in the world and we don't it's
not from the Schrodinger equation it's
from this additional requirement that we
sort of form a coherent classical thing
that does not keep entangling with the
rest of the world
Mark schwern says do you see chat GPT
and other AI tools as being useful in
your work perhaps either for research or
for teaching
yeah I think they will absolutely be
useful I mean for research uh it's very
easy to sort of use it as a search
engine right you just have to be super
duper careful because it will lie to you
but you should always be super duper
careful because anyone can lie to you
Wikipedia can lie to you Google can lie
to you Etc but if I say like you know I
just have forgotten what is the notation
that people usually use for this
constant right I can ask chat GPT and it
will tell me and then I will either go
oh yeah I knew that or I could double
check it by looking somewhere else right
so that's very useful in a very
straightforward way also you can use it
for programming right you can use GPT
tools to help you write computer
programs I found that very useful for
teaching I haven't been teaching uh
since the revolution happened so I'll be
doing that in the fall for the first
time and I think the right strategy is
just to lean in like not to pretend that
you can force your students not to use
it right students are going to use these
tools to write papers so I've seen
various ideas about what to do for
example you can assign an assignment
rather than saying write a paper on this
topic you can say let chat GPT write a
paper on this topic and then critique it
and the critique is what you're graded
on because chat GPT is not very
insightful it really you know it it is
very much like a student sort of just
core dumping a whole bunch of sentences
that sound good in the hopes that one of
them is the magic one that the professor
will give a good grade to right so
hopefully you can train your students to
do better than the current generation of
AIS are able to do
Max says do you have any advice for
meeting people from other academic
disciplines at Caltech or just in
general I'll be starting my physics PhD
there this fall but I'm coming from a
large state school where I was able to
make friends who studied philosophy art
history Etc I want to try my best to
stay well-rounded any tips
I don't think there are any specific
tips about Caltech or anything like that
I think that it's almost all in your
attitude right like the very fact that
you want to do it is the most important
thing you can go to seminars in other
departments and you know if you see
people over and over again you can
strike up conversations you can go to
classes taught by people you know can
sit in on a philosophy class or whatever
um I don't know where people live in the
for in grad school at Caltech I mean
typically uh what I did when I was a
grad student was lived in the dorms in
the first year and then moved into an
apartment after that and I met people in
the dorms and I made friends with them
for a very long time
um so I think it's just you know up to
you grad school is hard grad school is a
lot of work you certainly will hang out
with people who are in your department
because they're going to be the ones who
are helping you and uh and commiserating
with you along the way but I think that
your life will be richer if you if you
go outside a little bit I mean Caltech
as a particular place is less amenable
to that than most play places Caltech is
about getting your work done not about
stretching yourself outside of your
discipline but if you want to do it you
absolutely can
nalita s says do you personally believe
that we are both a physical system and a
spirit or just a physical system
if the first then how do those two
systems communicate the way they do if
the second then how does a physical
system alone give rise to a spirit
good you know this is the kind of thing
that I have thought about and I have a
very strong opinion that it's the latter
we are we are a physical system and any
Temptation you might want to talk about
us in terms of a soul or a spirit or
anything like that is just a slightly
loosey-goosey way of talking about
emergent properties of that physical
system I won't go in the details because
I did write a book where I went to
integrate details that's the big picture
so not the biggest ideas that's a
different book but in the big picture I
talk exactly about this issue and I
bring up the example of Princess
Elizabeth of bohemia who was a brilliant
thinker back in the day of Descartes and
she corresponded with Descartes and gave
him a hard time about exactly the idea
that he had that we are both a physical
system and a mental system both as both
a body and a mind separately and
Elizabeth pointed out how difficult that
is in practice to really pull it off it
goes back to the question we were just
answering a little bit ago how in the
world could non-physical things interact
with physical things maybe they could
but tell me exactly how they're going to
do it and no one is actually able to
tell me that
Chris Gunter says can you help me
understand a question on black holes and
time reversibility for a normal
irreversible event like a glass
shattering on the ground the bound up
energies dissipate into Sound and Motion
and heat we could imagine precisely that
same form of energy conspiring to arrive
at just the right moment to reinvigorate
the glass and put it back on the table
not impossible just discountably
unlikely can such a thing be true for a
book falling into a black hole can some
conspiracy-minded forces arrive at just
the right time to let us see the books
spontaneously arise from The Event
Horizon this gets described as
impossible in popular literature not
merely unlikely do we need Hawking
radiation to make this happen
well
you could have Hawking radiation spit
out a book it's super duper unlikely but
you know there's a probability that's
going to happen you could calculate the
probability but that wouldn't be what
you're thinking of the issue is that in
a black hole as you make the black hole
there is already a Time orientation to
the event horizon the event the outside
of the black hole is in the past of the
Event Horizon and the future of the
black hole is in the future so it's not
like a glass shattering on the ground
there really is a bounce a boundary a
barrier that separates the past from the
future in the black hole what you can do
is Imagine time reversing the whole
shebang and then you get a white hole
and a white hole is also an event
horizon where the interior is in the
past and the exterior is in the future
and it would spit things out what would
those things being spit out be very very
low entropy Etc that is is harder to say
because in the real world there aren't
any white holes out there
um but you know the Big Bang is kind of
like that the Big Bang is a low entropy
singularity in the past so there's some
commonalities there but I think that the
short answer to what you're asking is
that the very idea of a black hole is by
itself irreversible
Nick B says how differently would an
intelligent alien perceive the universe
and what effect would that have on their
physics I really enjoyed your
conversation with Thomas hertog
especially the section where he talked
about moving from a God's eye view to a
worm's eye view the idea that any
perspective of cosmology depends on
who's looking got me thinking about an
alien's eye view in your session with
arik kirschenbaum how different could an
alien physics or cosmological Theory be
given that they are looking at the same
universe but perceiving it very
differently eyes that see a very
different frequency of light or so forth
well I don't know is the short answer
because I'm not an alien I've never met
any to to talk to them I do have a
suspicion I mean of course
aliens could be very very different than
we are they could have very different
senses not just our recursion bound but
also the conversation with Ed young is
about how the sensorium of different
species right here on Earth are actually
are actually very very different from
one to the other but at the same time
though sansoria are putting us in touch
with the same external reality right uh
I am perceiving a desk right in front of
me on which my computer and my
microphone are on no sensible alien
would deny the existence of this desk
just because they have different sensory
apparatuses so my strong suspicion is
that the central pieces of physics as
developed by aliens are going to be the
same as the central pieces of physics
developed by us could be wrong about
that like I said but I do think that you
know it's it's important to recognize
that the ways aliens work could be very
different but we still live in the same
universe with the same underlying
physical things happening
Maxine says I need help reconciling
something based on my naive
understanding of quantum mechanics
specifically what intuitively prevents
the uncertainty principle from allowing
a particle to travel faster than light
my understanding is that if we observe
the position of a particle more and more
precisely the velocity becomes more and
more uncertain if we measure the
position of approaching exactly in
principle what prevents the particle
from traveling outside of the light cone
in the next instant
well
you know it's there are details here
okay I'm I I hate to say it but
sometimes the description of things like
the uncertainty principle in words don't
quite measure up to what you need here I
mean it's not actually position and
velocity that are limited by the
uncertainty principle it's position and
momentum okay and you can get momentum
to be bigger and bigger and bigger
without ever going faster than the speed
of light uh in relativity momentum
approaches Infinity as you approach the
speed of light so there's no reason just
to say I'm going to measure the position
so accurately that I have to include
velocities greater than light all you
have to do is include momenta that are
very very big in your uncertainty and
you can do that so so there's no problem
there with violating the speed of light
but the other thing to do just just
because I have the opportunity to do it
is to say as I like to say and I will go
on about at some length in uh Volume 2
of the biggest ideas in the universe the
uncertainty principle should not be in
interpreted as saying that
if You observe the position of a
particle the velocity becomes more and
more uncertain ultimately the
uncertainty principle is is not about
observations and ultimately there's no
such thing as the position or the
velocity or the momentum of the particle
those are possible observational
outcomes those are not things that exist
when you're not observing it the better
way to think about the uncertainty
principle is there are wave functions
there are quantum States and they have
predicted spreads or uncertainties or
standard deviations in the possible
measurement outcomes for momentum and
for
um
position and there is no wave function
for which the possible measurement
outcomes are simultaneously zero in both
position and momentum at the same time
that's what that's one way of thinking
about the uncertainty principle there
are other ways of thinking about it but
that's the basic idea
The Great Deceiver asks a priority
question saying given your excellent
communication skills I'm super curious
to know if you are familiar with or have
taken any courses in general semantics
General semantics is defined as
concerned with how events translate to
perceptions how they are further
Modified by the names and labels we
applied to them and how we might gain a
measure of control over our cognitive
emotional and behavioral responses
frankly I believe that the limits of
language lie at the heart of many
problems in physics and philosophy
so I've heard of General semantics but
no I've not taken any courses read any
books in it or anything like that I you
know I do think that both physicists and
philosophers have their own techniques
for trying to get things right as far as
definitions and meanings and semantics
is generally concerned
um I'm very happy to imagine that they
fail that they don't do a good job in
particular specific circumstances but I
don't want to you know tar them with the
brush of failing in some general way I
think you need to be careful about what
exact questions you're talking about
there
Darren Rogers says how would we ever
know if we arrived at a brute fact what
is the difference between a brute fact
and something that we can't yet figure
out an explanation for well a brute fact
is one where there is no explanation
that's the difference the important
question you asked is the first one how
would we ever know if we arrived at a
brute fact and the answer is we wouldn't
that's okay you know we we never know
lots of things we never know for certain
if our theories of physics are correct
right we do the best we can we try to
understand the universe we say you know
all right here's my best current idea
law of gravity or whatever it is
likewise I say my current best
understanding is that the following
thing is a brute fact but maybe it's not
maybe we can keep looking good you can
keep looking the only thing to keep in
mind is it might be a brute fact I can't
promise you that this or this this or
that fact about the universe is brute
has no further deeper explanation but
that doesn't mean that I I can't believe
that it could be that I that I must be
driven to find some deeper explanation I
have to keep in mind the possibility
that no such deeper explanation exists
okay the last question for today comes
from David Dubrow who says a previous
AMA question about living a thousand
years made me think about the possible
limits of our episodic memory
if our sense of identity is dependent on
our episodic memories and we lived many
hundreds of years would we lose so much
of our episodic memories from when we
were younger that we would not be
anything close to the same person we
were in previous centuries well the
honest answer here is I don't know
because again just like I've never met
aliens I have also not lived for
hundreds of years or thousands of years
or whatever it does seem very plausible
to me in fact I would be shocked if
someone thought that you could live for
thousands of years
and not be a very different person I
mean I'm a pretty different person than
I was when I was 10 years old which is
Believe Me Not hundreds of years ago
it's a while ago
um so I would like to think that it's
very natural if you live for hundreds of
years further you would turn into a
different person part of it would be
that your memories would be different
um of course if we actually get
technology to extend our lifespans that
long we might also have technology to
improve our worries right and maybe
that's not just improving our brains
maybe that's in as Andy Clark talked
about with the extended mind hypothesis
maybe that's offloading some memories to
our hard drive or something like that
right very plausible in the far future
where we're imagining living for
thousands of years so I think it's going
to be
interesting because you know we have so
much intuition so much Fielding for what
it means to be human to me to be a
person to be a self that has been
trained over all of human history and
now we are on the cusp of changing those
things in dramatic interesting ways
right through uh technology and brain
computer interfaces like we talked with
Nita farhani about
um but also possibly longevity Gene
editing things like that all sorts of
biological advances that we haven't even
yet foreseen so it's going to be very
very interesting how people want to hold
on to what we used to be and how we
adapt to what we're going to become it's
very fun to think about very hard to get
it right I think that the the goal is
less to try to figure out what actually
things will be like and to try to rather
scope out the space of possibilities so
that we are aware of whatever might
happen next and maybe we plan for it
just a little bit that's all we got for
this month thanks for tuning in thanks
as always for your support of the
mindscape podcast bye bye
[Music]
mama